GOOD MORNING AGAIN THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON LABOR
PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT AND
RETIREMENT WILL COME TO ORDER.
IN RESPONSE TO THE CLOVER
NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT PUB THE PUBLIC SENATORS
AND SENATE STAFF WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE WILL BE HOLDING AN
ESSENTIAL HEARING. AND HAS MADE
THE NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS TO
NORMAL PRACTICES IN ORDER TO
ENSURE THAT THE PUBLIC
CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS TO THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. WHILE
CONDUCTING THE HEARING IN A WAY
THAT PROTECTS THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF THE PUBLIC AND OUR
EMPLOYEES FOR ALL INDIVIDUALS
WISHING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT. THE PARTICIPANT TOLL
FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IS
POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. IT WILL BE DISPLAYED
ON THE SCREEN AND I WILL
ANNOUNCE IT HERE. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS ONE EIGHT
FOUR FOUR. TWO NINE ONE SIX
THREE SIX FOUR IN THE ACCESS
CODE IS. SEVEN FOUR SIX SIX ONE
ZERO THREE. WHEN WE MOVED TO
PUBLIC COMMENT TO A MODERATOR
WILL IDENTIFY YOU INDIVIDUALLY
OPEN YOUR LINE AND AT THAT TIME
YOU MAY ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE.
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR
US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO
AVOID ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK YOU
MUST MUTE THE DEVICE YOU WERE
WATCHING. THE HEARING ON SO
PLEASE MUTE THE DEVICE YOU'RE
WATCHING THE HEARING ON PRIOR
TO GIVING TESTIMONY OVER THE
PHONE. IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE
HEAR FROM YOU AND WE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE. I WOMAN TOOK
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY IN ANY
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE DISRUPTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE. TO HAVE OR
HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS MUTED.
EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE. S. CAN DOT FOR
HEARING TO. CLOSE TO THE SAME
MAN AS IS CUSTOMARY THERE MAY
BE SOME LAG TIMES FOR
PARTICIPANTS TO PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL AND PATIENT TO ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE HEARD.
SO WE HAVE ONE BILL ON TODAY'S
AGENDA. BUT BEFORE WE HEAR THE
PRESENTATION ON THAT BILL LET'S
ESTABLISH A QUORUM MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MEMBERS PLEASE TURN ON YOUR
MICROPHONES FOR THE PURPOSE OF
ROLE CENTER HILL HERE. CENTER
MOREAU. CENTER JACKSON HERE
SENATOR MITCHELL HERE SENATOR
PAN HERE. WE DO HAVE A QUORUM
ESTABLISHED. SHOULD YOU DO A
DUE TO CONSTRAINTS REGARDING
THE LANES OF HEARINGS
TECHNOLOGY CONSIDERATIONS AND
NEW CLEANING PROTOCOLS
COMMITTEES WILL INSTITUTE TIME
LIMITS ON TESTIMONY ACCORDINGLY
EACH SIDE WILL ONLY BE
PERMITTED A TOTAL OF THREE
MINUTES FOR THOSE WITNESSES
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION ALL OTHERS WISHING
TO TESTIFY MUST LIMIT THEIR
COMMENTS TO THEIR NAME. THEIR
AFFILIATION AND THEIR POSITION
ON THE MEASURES ONLY. SO TODAY
WE HAVE ONE. ITEM IN THAT IS A
CA FIVE. SO WELL WELCOME TO YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER. BACK TO EVER
YOU MAY PRESENT A CA FIVE. GOOD
MORNING- THE CHAIRMAN AND HERE
AND PLEASE TODAY TO PRESENT TO
YOU A CA FIVE THE CALIFORNIA
ACT ECONOMIC PROSPERITY AND
OPPORTUNITY FOR ALL. THIS
MEASURE WILL ALLOW CALIFORNIA'S
EFFORTS TO TAKE MEANINGFUL
STEPS TO MINIMIZE INEQUALITY
AND PROMOTE ECONOMIC FAIRNESS
FOR ALL. AC A FIVE SIX TO
PREVENT CONTINUE DISCRIMINATION
AGAINST WOMEN AND PEOPLE OF
COLOR BY ALLOWING GENDER RACIAL
AND ETHNIC DIVERSITY TO BE
CONSIDERED AS ONE OF THE MANY
FACTORS IN PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT
PUBLIC CONTRACTING AND PUBLIC
EDUCATION. IN NINETEEN NINETY
SIX VOTERS PASSED PROPOSITION
TOOL NINE WHICH INTO THE USE OF
RACE AND GENDER CONSCIOUS
DECISION MAKING IN CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC SECTOR. THIS CHANGE
WOULD CALIFORNIA'S STEP BACK
FROM THE NATION BEING ONLY ONE
OF EIGHT STATES THAT HAVE THIS
BAN ON EQUAL OPPORTUNITY AND
SERVES AS AN IMPEDIMENT TO
LOCAL AND STATE POLICIES TO
ADDRESS THE ECONOMIC AND SOCIAL
DISPARITIES EXPERIENCED BY
WOMEN. AND PEOPLE OF COLOR.
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FIFTEEN
STUDY WOMEN OWNED AND MINORITY
OWNED BUSINESSES CONSERVATIVELY
LOSE OVER ONE POINT ONE BILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR. THE TO THE
PASSAGE OF PROPOSITION TOOL
NINE. CALIFORNIA WHAT FROM
BEING ONE OF THE TOP PERFORMING
STATES IN THE COUNTRY. IN THE
EARLY NINETEEN NINETIES WITH
OUR CALTRANS DISADVANTAGED
BUSINESS ENTERPRISE
CONTRACTING. TO ONE OF THE TWO
WORST PERFORMING STATES
RELATIVE TO ITS DIVERSITY
PUTTING IT IN THE COMPANY OF
STATES WITH MUCH LESS THE BURKE
BE SUCH AS NEBRASKA AND
VERMONT. EMPLOYMENT
DISCRIMINATION REMAINS
PERSISTENT ACCORDING TO RECENT
RESEARCH 27% OF ASIAN AMERICANS
31% OF NATIVE AMERICANS 33% OF
LATINOS AND 56% OF AFRICAN
AMERICANS. HAVE EXPERIENCED
DISCRIMINATION WHEN APPLYING
JOBS. WOMEN AND PEOPLE OF COLOR
ALSO WITHSTAND HIGH LEVELS OF
DISCRIMINATION WHEN SEEKING
PROMOTION OR WILL PAY.
CALIFORNIA'S PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT
DATA REVEALS THAT WOMEN AND
PEOPLE OF COLOR CONTINUE TO BE
UNDER REPRESENTED AND UNDER
VALUE ESPECIALLY IN HIGH LEVEL
EXECUTIVE POSITIONS THAT COME
WITH INCREASED RESPONSIBILITY.
POLICY IMPLEMENTATION CONTROL
AND COMPENSATION. IN ADDITION A
SEVERAL RESEARCH DEMONSTRATES
THAT THE MOST READ RELATIVE
REPRESENTATIVE AND REFLECTIVE
OUR CIVIL RIGHTS SERVANTS AND
PUBLIC AGENCIES ARE THE MORE
RESPONSIVE GOVERNMENT TENDS TO
BE. RESEARCH DEMONSTRATES THAT
MINORITY POLICE OFFICERS WERE
LESS LIKELY THAN WHITE OFFCERS
TO CHARACTERIZE MINORITY
CITIZENS AS HOSTILE WHEN
DIFFERENT TO LAW AND ORDER.
BLACK SO SHE WORKERS WERE MORE
LIKELY THAN THEIR WIVES
COWORKERS TO PROCEED BLACK
CLIENTS FAVORABLY. IT IS ALSO
WIDELY RECOGNIZED THE TEACHER
DIVERSITY CAN HAVE PROFOUND
EFFECTS ON CLOSING THE
ACHIEVEMENT GAP AND STUDENT
SUCCESS FOR ALL STUDENTS
ESPECIALLY STUDENTS OF COLOR
WHO MORE THAN THREE QUARTERS OF
OUR STUDENT BODY. BUT WE REMAIN
AT A CRISIS POINT WITH OUR
FAILURE TO RECRUIT. IT TWO
DOLLAR. ESPECIALLY WOMEN
CRITICAL LIKE MASS SCIENCE AND
TECHNOLOGY BECAUSE OF THE BEER
IS A PROP TWO OH NINE.
CURRENTLY PROP TWO NINE STANDS
IN THE WAY OF CALIFORNIA EVEN
GIVEN PUBLIC DOLLARS TO
PROGRAMS LIKE SCIENCE CAMP FOR
GIRLS. SUCH PROGRAMS WOULD HAVE
WOULD HAVE DROPPED THE FOCUS ON
GIRLS OR RELY EXCLUSIVELY ON
PRIVATE DONATIONS. TRUCKS WILL
BE AREAS SUCH AS PROP TWO OH
NINE HAVE LEFT WOMEN IN
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR WITH A
RELENTLESS WEALTH GAP. MORE
VULNERABLE TO THE VIRUS AT
HIGHER RISK OF UNEMPLOYMENT AND
WITH FEWER INVESTMENT
OPPORTUNITIES FOR SMALL
BUSINESSES. CALIFORNIA DESERVES
MORE THAN JUST RECOVERY FROM
COLD AT NINETEEN WE MUST COMMIT
TO WORKING TOWARD A STRONGER
MORE EQUITABLE CALIFORNIA
WONDERFUL FAMILY. THE COVERT
NINETEEN HAS DONE TO WHEN
PEOPLE OF COLOR IN THE STATE.
TO RESPOND WE NEED INTENTIONAL
AND FOR PER AND PROPORTIONALLY
TARGETED REMEDIES TO HELP THESE
COMMUNITIES IN A WAY THE PROP
TWO OH NINE LARGELY FOR BE IT.
BUT NEARLY TWENTY FIVE YEARS
POP TOOL NINE HAS BLINDED OUR
LAWS AND INSTITUTIONS TO THE
BEER IS FACED BY WOMEN AND
PEOPLE OF COLOR. IT HAS HURT
AND NOT CALIFORNIA'S BY
PROHIBITING TIME TESTED EQUAL
OPPORTUNITY PROGRAMS LIKE
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION THE BULLS TO
EDUCATION AND JOB OPPORTUNITIES
FOR WOMEN AND PEOPLE OF COLOR.
DATA SUGGEST THAT WE ARE NOT
CURRENTLY LIVING IN A COLOR
BLIND SOCIETY. INSTEAD THE DATA
SUGGEST THAT WE DEEPLY EQUAL
SOCIETY WITH THE TOOLS TO
COMPETE IN SOCIETY UNEVENLY
DISTRIBUTED INDUSTRY WITHIN A
MATTER THAT PERPETUATES
INEQUALITY BETWEEN RACES AND
GENDERS AT ALL LEVELS OF CLASS
AND SCIETY. THE COLLECTIVE
ACTIONS WE HAVE SEEN AROUND THE
REPRESENTS AND CALL SISTER
CHANGE. WHEN YOU BOOK IT SHOULD
BE THE- TO REVISIT AND
EXPRESSED VIEWS. WOMEN FOR JIM
BIAS DESPAIR. WITH A CHOICE
EVERY THE BAN ON EQUAL
OPPORTUNITY. ACA FIVE HAS THE
SUPPORT OF OVER TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY DIVERSE CIVIL RIGHTS
ORGANIZATIONS. LABOR BUSINESS
AND COMMUNITY LET ORGANIZATIONS
INCLUDING CHINESE AMERICANS FOR
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION. EQUAL
JUSTICE SOCIETY IT TRUST WES SB
THIRTY TWO NINETY NINE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF WOMEN BUSINESS
OWNERS. CALIFORNIA STATE
EMPLOYEES WITH DISABILITIES AND
THE CALIFORNIA NURSES
ASSOCIATION HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION JUST NAME A FEW.
HERE TO TESTIFY- ON BEHALF OF
THE SUPPORT OF THE BILL OVER
THE PHONE. IT'S BEEN PAN CODES
THAT COULD DIRETOR OF THE
CHINESE FOR AFFIRMATIVE ACTION.
THANK YOU A LOT. LIVE BURGER
WHO'S THE PRESIDENT OF ASSAMESE
LOCAL. THIRTY TWO NINETY NINE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH TALKED
WEBER THIS WOULD THE MODERATOR
GO TO THE- PRINCIPLE- WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT. CATHERINE LIVE
ORDER INVENTION PAN. AND THEY
EACH HAVE A TOTAL THE TOTAL
TIME FOR THESE WITNESSES IS
THREE MINUTES. NUMBER NINE
EIGHT HOURS. MANY MEMBERS MY
NAME IS PENSION PAT ON THE CO
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF CHINESE
FOR PERMANENT ACTION IT'S A
FIVE IS ABOUT FIGHTING
DISCRIMINATION AND CREATING
OPPORTUNITY FOR ALL OF THE
EVIDENCE BUT PROTESTS IN THE
STREETS CALIFORNIANS FINANCE
SOLUTIONS THE STRUCTURAL RACISM
AND WHITE SUPREMACY. IF I WAS
NOT A CURE ALL BUT IT IS A
START BECAUSE FOR TWENTY FOUR
YEARS. I JOIN YOUR CULT PUBLIC
SECTOR AFFECT. THE DANCING
RACIAL. AND GENDER EQUITY. BY
BUYING THE CONSIDERATION OF
RACE AND GENDER PROP TWO OH
NINE HAS TIED THE HANDS OF
POLICY MAKERS. AS A RESULT TOO
MUCH OF THE STATUS QUO THAT
SKEWS PAPER. TO WALTER WHITE
MEN HAS PERSISTED. BUT NO
FURTHER THAN THE INEQUITIES
REVEAL BUT EQUIPMENT AND THAT.
MAC GLAD THAT PEOPLE. GREAT CAN
SURFACED IN THE SEARCH OF HATE
AND 90% OF SMALL IS ALL BY
WOMEN AND PEOPLE SHUT OUT OF
ECONOMIC STIMULUS. BUT THIS
CHALLENGES MY PRE THE CA BUYER
BECAUSE WELL AND ALL THE
CONTRACT PLAY GEORGE WE HAVE
NOT ABLE TO ENJOY HOW DOES. IS
TAKEN TOWARD SYSTEMS WITHOUT
CONFRONTING THE REAL WAYS THAT
RACE AND GENDER ARE ALWAYS IN
THE MIX PASSING EIGHTY EIGHT
FIVE WITH COACHES ATTEMPT
CHANGE VOTERS WOULD DECIDE
WHETHER IT IS RIGHT CAL TO BE
LONG ONLY EIGHT STATE REQUEST
LEAD YEAH OPTING OKAY LIKE A
FROM ACTION OR WHETHER CORPS
PERCENT WE SHOULD PROP TORN UP
TOGETHER WORKED MAKE CAL PERSON.
BROUGHT THANK YOU THANK YOU PAN
WEBER. MY NAME IS LIVE ORGAN
AND THE PRESS OF. ME THIRTY TWO
NINETY. UNION THAT WAS STARTED
BY A GROUP OF BLACK HISTORY AND
YOU SEE FOR. ACT THEIR FIRST
FIGHT WAS TO REPLACE THE WORD
CAN. BUT THEN HAS TO IN. IT WAS
ABOUT THEIR DIG. THEIR HUMANA.
A FEW YEARS LATER UC'S QUOTE
DOOR MATE HAD THAT SAME FIVE
AND ONE THERE FOR CON. THERE
DIG AS WOMEN. WHAT CAN YOU OUR
UNIONS WERE ON YOU CAMP. WE
HAVE WATCHED THE NUMBER OF
FACES. IS A SMALLER PERCENTAGE
OF THE STUDENT. SMALLER PERCENT
OF THE FACULTY EVERSION HUGE HE
BEGAN OUTSOURCING SERVICE JOBS
LIKE MINE THE PERCENT OF OUR
MEMBERS ARE BLACK HAS DROPPED
FROM NINETEEN PERCENT. IT HAS
DROPPED 37% TODAY IT TAKES A
LATINA HIRED AS A UC'S SERVICE
WORKER SIX YEARS BEFORE SHE
WILL BE PAID WHAT A WHITE MALE
SERVICE WORKER IS PAID ON DAY
ONE. THOSE WHO OPPOSE THE ACA
FINE SAY RACE SHOULD NOT
MATTER. BUT HISTORY MATTERS IN
CALIFORNIA'S HISTORY VERY
RECENT HISTORY PROVES THE REYES
DOES MATTER. BACK TO WEBER
PLEASE KNOW WE WILL BE WITH YOU
IN NOVEMBER THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SLICE BURGER- WE WILL NOW
MOVE TO ANYONE ELSE WANTING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT SO WE WILL
BEGIN WITH ANYONE IN THE PUBLIC
GALLERY HERE IN THE- CHAMBERS
WHO WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF ACA FIVE. SEE NO ONE
IS THERE ANYONE IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY WISHING TO SUPPORT TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF A CA FIVE.
ANYONE WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF ACA FIVE SEEING NO
ONE WISHINGTO SUPPORT THEIR WE
WILL NOW. MOVE TO. THE
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD- OF
THOSE PUBLIC WAITING TO TESTIFY
VIA TH TELECONFERENCE RIVAGE
TO MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE PROMPT THE INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF A SEE A FIVE WE WILL THEN
BEGIN. AND IF YOU COULD GIVE ME
A TOTAL NUMBER OF PEOPLE
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
I CURRENTLY WE HAVE. TWENTY
YEARS. FIFTY FIVE. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN ONLY IF YOUR AND
SUPPORT PRESS ONE ZERO AT THAT
TIME. IF YOU HAVEN'T ALREADY SO
THANK YOU HILARY DAN WENT
FLYING. HELLO ARE YOU READY
MARIE BY THE I AM IN ONE SECOND
BUT- I JUST WANTED TO MAKE A
COUPLE OF COMMENTS WE HAVE
SIXTY FIVE SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT-
ALL THE HEARING MUST IN TODAY
BY TWELVE THIRTY- AT THE LATEST
SO THAT WE CAN HAVE THE
NECESSARY CLEANING- IF THEY'RE
DONE IN THIS THESE CHAMBERS ARE
NOT ALL CALLERS MAY GET THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HEARD. BUT
THE COMMITTEE WILL MAKE EVERY
EFFORT TO DO SO IF COLORS ARE
NOT ABLE TO BE HEARD THROUGH
THE TELECONFERENCE LINE THEY
CAN SUBMIT IN WRITING OR CALL
THE COMMITTEE. AND WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THE DECORUM IS
MAINTAINED AT ALL TIMES THIS
MEANS OF PUBLIC COMMENT
CONSISTS OF INAPPROPRATE OR
INFLAMMATORY LANGUAGE
STATEMENTS OR OTHER TYPES OF
COMMENT CONSIDERED OFFENSIVE
YOU WILL BE REMOVED FROM THE
TELECONFERENCE. IN SUPPORT AND
PUBLIC COMMENT IS TAKEN FIRST
AND THEN WE WILL GO TO
OPPOSITION- IT AND IF YOU CALL
IN THE WRONG TIME WE WILL MOVE
ON TO THE NEXT CALLER IN ASK
YOU TO CALL BACK AT APPROPRIATE
TIME FOR TESTIMONY- THE DUE TO
THE TIME CONSTRAINTS THAT WE
HAVE WE WILL LIMIT. THE CALLS
FROM TELECONFERENCE LINE FOR
THE IN SUPPORT AND THOSE IN
OPPOSITION TO ONE HOUR PER
SUPPORT ONE HOUR FOR OPPOSITION
SO WE WILL THAT IT SURE THE
FUTURE OF YOUR NECK YOUR THE H.
AND YOU. POSITION ON A
CONSCIOUS LIMIT MODERATE CAN BE
WITH THE FIRST CALLER PLEASE.
AND WE NOW HAVE NOT. YOU WE
WILL BEGIN WITH ONE. TWO
HUNDRED AND SIX. THANK YOU AND
AFTER A LEAD COUNSEL PUBLIC I.
AS THE HUMAN HAPPENED THAT
TRACK ITS RACIAL AND TRACTOR.
THE MIDDLE INTO FOR EVERYTHING
IF I WISHED I SUPPORT THE BILL
THANK YOU THANK YOU. THE FINE
ONE THIRTY THANK. GOOD MORNING
CHAIR MEMBERS MY NAME IS A
MANAGER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES- CHANCES
OFFICE TRANSPORTED YET BY THANK
YOU. BLACK LINE. TO SEVENTY. AT
NINE SEVEN ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YOU HAVEN'T ON MUTE. WE WILL GO
TO THE NEXT LINE. AND THIRTY. I
DID ANYONE EVER THOUGHT ALL THE
BIG WILL BE HAPPENING IN THE A
PAL AT B. EIGHTY ALLEN CONTROL
PACIFIC REGION. FOR YOUR
SUPPORT EIGHT EIGHT FIVE THANKS
SO MUCH THANK YOU FOR THE
TESTIMONY. NEXT HEADLINE FIFTY
FOUR. DO YOU HAVE IT ON MUTE
NINE FIFTY FOUR. WE WILL MOVE
TO THE NEXT LINE. NOT GOING ANY
ONLINE AT FOUR HUNDRED AND
THIRTY THREE. HI MY NAME IS SAM
COHN- GRADUATE STUDET AT UC
BERKELEY- MEMBER OF UAW LOCAL
TO IT FIVE AND A RESEARCH THAT
WORK BERKELEY NATIONAL LAB
BEFORE IT DID. THANK YOU. NEXT
DEADLINE. FORTY TWO. HELLO THIS
IS THE U. FROM SAN DIEGO I
STRONGLY OPPOSED TO A CA FIVE
BECAUSE GIVEN RACIAL AND GENDER
PREFERENCES ANOTHER. THIS IS
NOT AN OPPOSITION MA'AM. YOU'RE
CALLING AT THE WRONG TIME
PLEASE CALL BACK. GOING TO THE
NEXT COLUMN MODERATOR PLEASE.
NEXT DEADLINE TO THIRTY TWO.
YOU HAVE A COMMENT. HELLO I AM.
YEAH I HAD. I'M I DON'T WHAT
THE IF YOU'RE CALLING THE WRONG
TIME MA'AM YOU SHOULD CALL BACK
DURING THE OPPOSITION TIME
THESE ARE FOR THOSE WHO WERE
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF A CA
FIVE. PLEASE MOVE ON MODERATOR
BUT THAT'LL- LINE FOR TWENTY
SIX. I HAD MINE FOR TWENTY SIX.
YEAH BUT THEN AGAIN. AFTER MY
CURRENT ONLY ABOUT THAT I AM IF
YOU ARE IN PART WE'RE GONNA
MOVE NINE TO. TEN. HI MY NAME
IS MAYOR DHALIWAL AND I'M
CALLING. ON BEHALF OF THE
OPPOSITION OPPORTUNITY FOR ALL
COALITION. WAIT REPRESENTS OVER
ONE HUNDRED ORGANIZATIONS IN
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT
EIGHTY FIVE. THANK YOU. NEXT
DEADLINE TO. JENNIFER OF
NINETEEN SIXTY TWO. HE I LIVE
ON MY. EIGHT THREE FOUR. CAN
YOU HEAR ME. YEAH. SB EIGHTY
I'LL YELL I'M CALIFORNIA AND
DONE BEFORE FIVE THANK YOU.
NEXT DEADLINE IT. I HAD MY IF
YOU. GOT IT YET. WE'RE GONNA
MET I AM FIFTY THANK. NINE
FIFTY SIX. YOU HAVE SEEN IT.
ARE GONNA MET LINE ONE EIGHTY
ONE. BUT MANY MOONS HOW WORK
FROM- THE WORK I REPRESENTED
THE OTHER ASIAN COMMUNITY DO
YOU MIND AND WELL I ONLY
OPPOSED THE ZERO WERE. ON
SUPPORT BY THOSE WHO PLEASE
CALL BACK AND SPEAK AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME WE'RE TALKING
THOSE IN SUPPORT AND PLEASE
WHEN YOU ARE LISTENING TO THE
HEARING- YOU SHOULD HAVE-
LISTEN ON YOUR PHONE NOT ON THE
COMPUTER BECAUSE IS A BLACK
TIME MINUTE DELAYS YOU CAN
SPEAK RIGHT AWAY AND WHEN YOU
HEAR THAT SO. PLEASE PROCEED
MODERATOR. NEXT DEADLINE THANK
THE BILL. YES HELLO- GOOD
MORNING- CHAIR MEMBERS- MY NAME
IS CLASS ON ON BEHALF OF THE UC
STUDENT ASSOCIATION REPRESENTS
OVER TWO HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
FIVE THOUSAND STUDENTS ACROSS
THE STREET AND WE ARE STRONG
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY FIVE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT DEADLINE
NINETY FOUR. YOU HAVEN'T
THOUGHT MUTE MY NINETY FOUR.
THE BETTER THE NEXT TIME THAT.
ONE HUNDRED EIGHTY SEVEN. I
NEED A NUMBER I. HELLO I TOLD
EIGHTY FINALS WILL BE OPPOSE
TESTIMONY WILL BE AFTER SUPPORT
PLEASE CALL BACK AND YEAH.
PLEASE GOING MODERATOR. NEXT
DEADLINE WHY DON'T THANK. HI
CAN YOU HEAR ME YES YEAH. MY
NAME IS LEAH REYNOLDS I'M A
UNDERGRADUATE STUDENT AT UC
SANTA BARBARA AND I'M THE
CURRENT EXTERNAL BATES PRESENT
STATEWIDE AFFAIRS FOR THE SHE
DIDN'T THAT YOU CAN SANTA
BARBARA WHICH REPRESENTS ALL
THE UNDERGRADUATE INSTITUTION
AND I'M CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY EIGHT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT DEADLINE
SIXTEEN. TWO ONE SIX. MY GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS. LIBERTY TO
TALK TO YOU THE RIVERSIDE
CALLING INSURANCE. RIGHT THANK
YOU ACCESS LINE OF ONE FORTY
FOUR. NINE ONE FORTY PART OF IT
THAT BUTTE. WE WILL GO TO THE
NEXT I AM. GOING TO BE TWO
TWENTY FOUR. HI MY NAME IS
DANIEL HOW. AND I AM A STUDENT
AT THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
RIVERSIDE I AM A CONSTITUENT
SENATOR MIKE MORALE AND IN
STRONGLY IN SUPPORT OF A SEEING
FIVE. THANK YOU. ACCESS LINE
THIRTY ONE. THERE ARE.
ASSEMBLYMAN ALL FOR. OPERATE IN
THE LOCAL PUT. STRONG FOR OKAY
PAGE NOT. THANK YOU. NEXT
DEADLINE. ONE FIFTY FIVE. BY
INTERNET CAN ON BEHALF OF THE
STUDENT SENATE OF CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES REPRESENTING
OVER TWO POINT ONE MILLION
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS AND
SOME STRONG SUPPORT OF EIGHT
FIVE THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT
DEADLINE ONE THIRTY NINE. ONE
THIRTY NINE I HAD. WHAT ARE THE
NEXT ONE. NINE ONE SIXTY THREE.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS TO
REQUIRE PALLADIO AS LOS ANGELES
AND I'M CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY EIGHT FIVE
THANK YOU THANK YOU. NEXT
DEADLINE WON ALL FOUR. AND MY
NAME IS LOOK MUMBLE CARI AND
I'VE LIVED IN NEW YORK
CALIFORNIA TO IT- THUNDER TONI
ATKINS I MEAN ASIAN AMERICAN
STUDENT AND I HEARD SENATOR
THAT THE COMMITTEE TO VOTE YES
ON IT THE A. FIVE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. NEXT DEADLINE. ONE
TWENTY FIVE. YOU HAVE A TIME
YET. LINE ONE TWENTY FIVE.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO THE NEXT
ONE. NINE EIGHTY ONE. GO AHEAD
LINE EIGHTY ONE. JUST ANOTHER
REMINDER TO PLEASE LISTEN TO
THE HEARING ON YOUR TELEPHONE
AND NOT THROUGH THE COMPUTER-
THAT WE CAN PROPERLY SPEAK.
WEARING THE NEXT LINE ONE SIXTY
FOUR. GOOD MORNING BUT THE
DEGREE CARL FROM EIGHTY ONE
WHAT THE ANALYST AND I STRONG
WITH THE COURT EIGHTY EIGHT
FIVE THANK YOU. NEXT DEADLINE
JAN THIRTY NINE. MY NAME IS
DANTE DIMARTINO AND WHAT
CALIFORNIANS SPECIFICALLY
JUSTICE AND WE'RE VERY STRONG
SUPPORT AND EIGHTY FIVE THANK
YOU THANK YOU. NEXT DEADLINE OF
ONE SEVENTY TWO. GOODMORNING
MY NAME IS JACQUELINE STERN AND
I'M THEY HAVE THE CONSUMER
ATTORNEY THE CALIFORNIA AND
WE'RE AS STRONG SUPPORTER AC
FIVE. THANK YOU THANK YOU. NOW
THAT'S MY POINT FIVE. RIGHT
CLICK THE STANLEY EIGHT
SUPPORTER A DELAY IN SACRAMENTO
AND STRONG SUPPORT OF EIGHTY
EIGHT FIVE. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
BACK LINE ONE ONLINE. HELLO YES
WE HAD. GOOD MORNING SENATOR
THAT MY NAME IS MARIA THOMAS
I'M CALLING FROM HOLLISTER
CALIFORNIA AND I'M CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT AS EASY A FIVE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT
DEADLINE ONE NINETY FIVE. HI MY
NAME IS ONE THE NOT A GLOBAL.
AND I'M BALLOTS BOB ONE
THOUSAND. NINE YEAH I. EIGHT
EIGHT. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NEXT DEADLINE ONE NINETY FOUR.
HELLO MY NAME IS ABDUL RAHIM I
MEET AND WITH THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF BLACK
CONTRACTORS AND I'M CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF AC EIGHT FIVE. THANK
YOU. ACCESS LINE WHEN I AM. I.
FOR ERIN THE OWNER AND- BY THE
END OF BENEFIT THE BOOK BY. AND
IF THE KNOB THOUGH NUMBER AND
PRESIDENT OF OUR ACCOUNT ABOUT
CHAPTER. I SUPPORT THE EIGHT
FIVE. THANK YOU THANK YOU. NEXT
HEADLINE TO TWELVE. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS JOHN CALLING
FROM THE MAIL CALIFORNIA NINE
IN STRONG SUPPORT AND EIGHTY
FIVE THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. ACCESS LINE ONE OH THREE.
HI MY NAME IS ONE MAJOR IT AND
I'M- CARE AT THAT CALIFORNIA
AGAIN DEMOCRATS WOMEN OFTEN AND
I'M CALLING FROM. EIGHT THANK
YOU FOR CALLING. NEXT LINE ONE
FORTY ONE. HELLO YEAH HI. HOW
LONG ME YOU. I'M I WONDER IF
MARKETS I DON'T. AND I'M
LOOKING BILL DABABNEH
AFFILIATED YOU REMARKS OFTEN
THAN I AM. EIGHTY FIVE. THANK
YOU. NEXT DEADLINE TO TWENTY
THREE. HI MY NAME IS THAT AS
SOMEONE SIGNED YOU I AM FROM
LOS ANGELES AND I AM CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AC EIGHT FIVE
THANK YOU THANK YOU. NEXT
DEADLINE FIFTY FIVE ONE MORE. I
HAD MY- HI MY NAME IS CAROLYN
DAVIS NINE SMALL BUSINESS
OWNERS AND I AM IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY EIGHT FIVE
AND I URGE THE COMMITTEE TO
VOTE YES ON EIGHTY EIGHT FIVE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NEXT DEADLINE TO SIX ONE. GOOD
MORNING. YES WE HEAR YOU. MY
NAME IS ROBERT ALLEN I'M THE
EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF WHAT'S
BEEN IN THAT CASE THEN YOU L.
L. BE ANOTHER NOW MOST. WOMEN
BUSINESS OWNERS ALTHOUGH. I
SUPPORT WHY. THANK YOU.
NECKLINE. EIGHT GOOD MORNING
CHAIR MEMBERS MY NAME KANILANG
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA EMPLOYMENT LAWYERS
ASSOCIATION I'M NOT CHINESE
AMERICAN AND STRONG SUPPORT OF
EIGHTY EIGHT THANK YOU THANK
YOU. NEXT DEADLINE FORTY. AT
FOUR EIGHT ZERO. HI MY NAME IS
AND I'M A STUDENT OF THE UC
RIVERSIDE AND I'M CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT EIGHTY EIGHT
FIVE. THANK YOU. NEXT DEADLINE
FIFTEENTH AT FIVE ZERO. CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES WE. HI MY NAME IS
NATALIE HATCHER I'M CALLING ON
BEHALF AB A LOS LOS ANGELES
FALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
BASICALLY EIGHT FIVE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. NEXT HEADLINE
SEVENTY TWO. HI MY NAME IS
MAUREEN FINANCE I'M CALLING
FROM UC BERKELEY CLEAN AND
STRONG SUPPORT EIGHTY EIGHT
FIVE THANK YOU THANK YOU. NEXT
FIVE ONE OWN NINE. OUTLINED ONE
HUNDRED NINE. WHAT THE NECKLINE.
SIXTY FIVE. HI MY NAME IS BECCA
PA GOOD TO MEET YOU SAN DIEGO
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
EIGHTY EIGHT FIVE THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT
DEADLINE FOR TWENTY ONE. YEAH
MY NAME. JAMES BORROWING I'M A
MEMBER OF THE ALAMEDA
DEMOCRATIC COMMITTEE. YOUR
CALIFORNIA AND I'M CALLING ON
AT EIGHT EIGHT THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. BACK LINE ONE
NINETY ONE. MY NINETY ONE YEAH
THAT. OVER THE NEXT LINE OF
FIFTY ONE. ECONOMY SITTING WITH
EQUAL JUSTICE SOCIETY IN OPEN
LOW PROBABLY JOIN THE FIVE
HUNDRED ORGANIZATIONS AND
COMMUNITY LEADERS IN THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR ALL COALITION
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF ACA
COMPLIANT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU. ACCESS LINE ONE
TWENTY EIGHT. HI MY NAME IS
HARLEY BUT HE DIDN'T AND THE
CURRENT CHIEF OF STAFF OF THE
OFFICE OF THE EXTERNAL VICE
PRESIDENT. AND BUT I THINK AND
I'M CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THE- THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NINE NINE FOUR FIFTY TWO. I AM.
RIDLEY I'M ALSO PART OF THE
INGREDIENTS. A PART OF.
SIXTY
THOUSAND GRAD STUDENT AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA AND
I'M ALSO THE DIRECTOR OF SOCIAL
JUSTICE CONCERNS TO THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
GRADUATE PROFESSIONAL STUDENTS
WILL BE REPRESENTS OVER HALF A
MILLION GRADUATES NATIONWIDE I
AM CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT AT
A CA FIVE. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MAC LINE WELL. HER NAME. FIND
EIGHT I HAD. BY THE NEXT ONE
LINE FOR FIFTY. I DID BRIAN ON
THE CALIFORNIA PACKAGES OKAY
SHOULD WORK CO SPONSORS A BY
THANK YOU THANK YOU. NOT
HEADLINE. TWENTY SIX. HEY THIS
IS ONE THAT THOUGHT ABOUT COVER
ON BEHALF OF THE ALLOW
CALIFORNIANS FOR TWO AND STRONG
SUPPORTER A FEW. THANK THAT OF
LINE. ONE SIXTY ONE. GOOD
MORNING. MY NAME IS OUR RATE
SHOULD. ACTIVE LIFE ONE NINETY.
AND WHAT ARE THE NEXT. ONE FOR
SIXTY THREE. HELLO YES YES THE
HEAD. YEAH GOOD MORNING MY NAME
IS ABOUT A KING I'M CALLING
WITH THE AT THE AT THE PROJECT
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
EIGHTY FIVE I'M AND WE
ENCOURAGE THE MEMBERS THE COURT
DAHLE WHILE EIGHT YEAH THANK
YOU. NEXT DEADLINE FOUR THIRTY
NINE. HI THERE. MY NAME IS
SENDING A REAL. I'M WITH KATE
BOB NEEDS WORK WE'RE A GROUP OF
PARENTS EDUCATORS STUDENTS- AND
PUBLIC EDUCATION ADVOCATES. ALL
AROUND IT CALIFORNIA. AND I WE
ARE IN FONG SUPPORT OF. EIGHTY
EIGHT FIVE. URGE THE COMMITTEE
IS THE YES ON A DATE THANK YOU
THANK YOU. ACTOR LINE. FOR
SIXTY EIGHT. THE HEADLINE FORTY
EIGHT. ALL RIGHT WE'RE GONNA
MOVEON DOT LINE FOR FIFTY THREE.
FOUR FIVE THREE. YEAH BUT I
MEAN IT. RIGHT UP YES AND I AM
PUTTING THAT FROM L. EIGHT I AM
HERE HIS STRONG HOLD. EIGHTY
EIGHT MY NAME PLEASE CALL BACK
DURING THE APPROPRIATE TIME FOR
OPPOSITION. THIS IS FOR SUPPORT
PLEASE MOVE ON MODERATOR. NEXT
DEADLINE FOR FIFTY NINE. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS DEREK BOK
WITH THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY AT WE'RE AND PROUD
SUPPORT AT EIGHTY EIGHT FIVE
THANK YOU THANK YOU. NEXT
DEADLINE ONE TWENTY NINE. HI
GOOD MORNING SENATORS MY NAME
IS JANE HEARD AND I'M A STUDENT
AT UC BERKELEY CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF EIGHTY EIGHT
FIVE. THANK YOU THANK YOU. NEXT
AND ONE OH EIGHT. GOOD MORNING
THIS GLORIA. YOUNG ADULT MALE.
AND I AND SUPPORT OF THE EIGHT.
THANK YOU. ACT TO SIXTEEN THAT
TWO SIX ZERO. HI THIS IS US
UNDER YES ON THE STATE POLICY
FOR CAPTIVITY AND HONOR COULD
BE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF ACA-
APPRECIATE THAT MEMBERS WORK
OUT THANK YOU VERY MUCH GOOD A
CALL SIDE. ACCESS LINE TO THE.
SEVEN GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
JUDY HYMAN I'M CALLING ON
BEHALF OF CONGREGATION BUT NAY
ISRAEL SACRAMENTO THE JEWISH
COMMUNITY RESOURCE CENTER OF
THE SACRAMENTO REGION AND THE
NATIONAL COUNCIL OF JEWISH
WOMEN SACRAMENTO IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY EIGHT FIVE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. ACCESS
LINE EIGHTY TWO. THE MORNING
MANY INCIDENTS THAT ROCK BILL
I'M EATING AND THE VICE
PRESIDENT OF EXTERNAL AFFAIRS
AT YOU EITHER I AND
REPRESENTATIVE OF THE UC
UNIFICATION REPRESENTING OVER
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
STUDENTS CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORTER EIGHTY FIVE THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THE NEXT LINE. FOR
TWENTY TWO. I HAVE NINE FORTY.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON DEADLINE
OR SIXTY ONE. GO AHEAD ONE.
NINE FOUR SIX ONE. WE ARE GOING
TO GO OUT THE NEXT. ONE NINE
FOUR EIGHT ZERO FOUR EIGHTY.
HELLO BUT BROWN BOOK CALLING ON
BEHALF OF MORE THAN THREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND MEDICAID IS
THE MEMBERS OF THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION AND STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. LACK OF
THAT A LOT OR IF THE THAT FOUR
FIVE ZERO. HI MANY YEAH ASIAN
AMERICANS AGAIN CALIFORNIA BUT
AT THE GATE. THANK YOU. NEXT
DEADLINE NINETY SIX. HI HELLO
MY NAME IS ORLANDO ACTORS AND I
AM- CO COORDINATOR. FOR RACIAL
JUSTICE NOW AT UC RIVERSIDE
CAMPUS AND I'M CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF EIGHTY FIVE.
THANK YOU. NEXT DEADLINE FOUR
NINETY THANK. GO AHEAD FOR
NINETY SIX. GOOD MORNING PARTS
AS THEIR AGO THE DS AND I'M
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION FOR BILINGUAL
EDUCATION AND CALIFORNIANS
TOGETHER AND WE ARE IN STOCK
STRONG SUPPORT OF ACA FIVE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT THEY
LOOK AT A LINE OR EIGHTY SEVEN.
I HAD MY PARTY. SEVEN FOUR
EIGHT SEVEN IN AND- IN. WE'RE
GOING TO LIVE. SEVENTY NINE. HI
GOOD MORNING CAN YOU HEAR ME
YES WE GET YEAH WE HEAR YOU. HI
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS JUSTIN
BIEBER NIKA QUITE A ON UNDER
YOUR TO DO NOT UC BERKELEY I'M
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE ACA BY. THANK YOU THANK YOU
FOR CALLING. NEXT LINE ONE FOR
YOU. GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
TERRA PARADE I WITH THE
NATIONAL POLITICAL THE
CALIFORNIA. HAVE PUBLIC. AND
CONSTITUENT NOW THE AND I SPEAK
OR DELAYED DELAYED A ORDER.
INTO OF EIGHT FIVE WE- OR-
THANK YOU. IN LINE TO THIRTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NINE TWO
THREE TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
AND WE'LL MOVE ON TO LINE
SEVENTY EIGHT MINE SEVENTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
MY NAME IN THE LAB I'M A PART
OF THAT. I USED IN MY FAULT. I
THANK THE FOUR EIGHT THREE FIVE
THANK THEM THANK YOU. I AM FOR
NINETY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
CRITICIZING THE CALIFORNIA
NURSES ASSOCIATION CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF ACA BY. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY. AND
NINE ONE FORTY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. AND AGAIN NINE ONE
FORTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING. MY NAME TO CALL
SHOE- REPRESENTING AND THOUSAND
PEOPLE ATTENDED COMMUNITY.
STRONGLY OPPOSED TO EIGHTY
EIGHT HI. THANK YOU. AND LINE
FIVE FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING ERIC- AMERO ON
BEHALF OF THE HISPANIC
ASSOCIATION OF COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES AND STRONG SUPPORT
SB THREE EIGHT FIVE THANK YOU
THANK YOU. AND NINE FIFTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NINE FIFTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. AND
MOVING ON TO LINE ONE FORTY
THREE ONE ONE FORTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
ALICIA SIX AND I'M THE VICE
PRESIDENT OF EXTERNAL AFFAIRS
EASY SAN DIEGO AND WE REPRESENT
AT UCSD AND WE ARE IN STRONG
THE COURT EASY EIGHT FIVE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. IN LINE
FOR EIGHTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK CHAIRMAN MEMBER
MEMBERS- BETWEEN ELEVEN ON
BEHALF OF THE CAMPAIGN BECAUSE
OF THE CHANGING CORPS AS A I.
THANK YOU. TEN NINE SIXTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
MY NAME IS IT OUT REALLY
COMMENT AND I'M A STUDENT AT UC
RIVERSIDE AND I'M CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT AT EIGHTY EIGHT
FIVE THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY. AND NINE FIVE
OR SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
NINE FIVE OH SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE CHECK YOUR MUTE. HI
THERE AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS A
LITTLE I'M WITH CALIFORNIANS
FOR SAFETY IN THOSE MOMENTS
STRONG SUPPORT OF EIGHTY EIGHT
FIVE THANK YOU THANK YOU. AND
NINE ONE SIXTY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS TO
THEIR CORE I MUST FORMER
STUDENT AT UC BERKELEY AND I'M
CALLING IN- TOO STRONG LEE
BEING SUPPORT THAT IS HI THANK
YOU THANK YOU. AND ONE ONE
TWENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I MEAN. I'M OF
THE OCEAN OKAY. AND NINE FIVE
OH NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI GOOD
MORNING AND MY NAME IS. EAGLE
LANE I'M CALLING FROM THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
BERKELEY I'M CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY FIVE IT I'M
THRILLED BY THE CALIFORNIA THE
BACK ALLEY. THE THANK YOU. ACT
OF NINETEEN THIRTY FIVE. NINE
THIRTY FIVE AM. WHAT KIND OF
THE NEXT ONE LINE. ONE NINETEEN
ONE ONE NINE. HELLO. I HAD. HI
MY NAME IS TERRA IDENTIFIED
UNDERGRADUATE STUDENT AT UC
BERKELEY CALLING IN SUPPORT OF
PCA FIVE THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT
DEADLINE FOR A FINAL. NINE FOUR
NINE. MEETING WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE TO THE NEXT ONE LINE
NINETY NINE ZERO. HELLO YES. HI
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS NOW AND
THEN AND THEN UP AND I'M THE
UNDERGRADUATE STUDENTS WHO ST
BERKELEY I'M CALLING SUPPORT A
PC. THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT
IN LINE TO TWENTY THREE. AT TWO
TWENTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
CHECK YOUR MUTE. WHAT ARE THE
NEXT ONE LINE FIVE TWENTY ONE.
THE MORNING- ABOUT A LACK ON
BEHALF OF THE GRANT AND THE OF
PUBLIC INSTRUCTION RIGHT THERE
MA'AM I SELECT THE COMPETITION
OFF A THIRD OF THE GREAT WORK
BECAUSE YOU'RE A. THREE
ACTUALLY I THINK YOU. NEXT
DEADLINE. FIVE FIFTY ONE. HELLO
MY NAME IS CHRISTINA HRISTINA
LAUGHTER ON THE LOWER RIGHT
BACK. AGAIN REPRESENTING BLACK
BLACK BOULDER NOT. NATION I'M
STUCK WITH THE PART. THANK YOU
LINE ONE TWENTY SEVEN. GO AHEAD
NINE ONE TWENTY SEVEN.
REMARKING THE JOSE I THINK
ALREADY I'LL BUT THE AC AND BAM
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT
DEADLINE. FIVE THIRTY FIVE
THREE ZERO. GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR NUMBER- KILEY REGULARLY
AT THE UNIVERSITY YEAH THE
UNIVERSITY. UNITY ROUTE THIS IS
A FIGHT BEING HEARD I FELT THE
PUT THIS ORDER IS NOT. THANK
YOU THANK YOU. NEXT DEADLINE.
FIVE SIXTY SIX. HEY GOOD
MORNING EVERY AMERICAN A
THOUSAND. HEY YOU THE CARD THE
NIGHT BUT THEN- HYATT THEM YOU
SHOULD I THINK JUST THAT YOU
NEED ARE YOU IN SUPPORT- AC
FIVE MEN. WHAT'S THE- GOAL OF
THE- OKAY MA'AM PLEASE MOVE ON
PONDERED IT. NEXT DEADLINE.
FIVE SIXTY NINE. GOOD MORNING
CARE MY NAME IS JACKIE TO WHOM
LONG AND I AND REX AND CAL
POPPING CALIFORNIA CAMPAIGN CO
CHAIR BY THE NORTHWARD TO AND
CON MAKE COLLEGE AS WELL AS
REPRESENTING MYSELF AS A
TRUSTEE OF THE WASHINGTON
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT AND IN
STRONG OF A DAY FIVE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. NEXT DEADLINE EIGHTY
NINE. GO AHEAD AND EIGHTY NINE
CHECK THEIR MAIL. IF YOU SEE
EIGHTY NINE YEAH GO AHEAD. OKAY
THANK YOU MY NAME IS CLOUDY ON
THE MENTOR PROGRAM MERRY
OCCASION FOR A DIRECTOR DANNY
IS BEATING A BLACK IT IS. AS
THE IT BACK AT. WE AND I'M THE
A ON. THANK YOU. EIGHTY NEXT
DEADLINE. SEVEN ONE. IN THE
ELECTION HE- FOR ALL OF LOS YOU
COULD ONLINE. THANKS ONLY OF
ALL THAT THIS IS REPORT NINE
LEAST PLEASE CALL BACK AT THE
APPROPRIATE FOR A- THANK YOU
MOVE ON A MODERATOR. NEXT
HEADLINE FIVE NINETY SIX. YES
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS BECAUSE
SANDRA JENNINGS AND I'M
PRESIDENT AND CEO OF THE
GREATER SACRAMENTO URBAN LEAGUE
I'M CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
URBAN LEAGUE AND ALL THAT
BERMAN LEAVING CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG SUPPORT ABC A HI THANK.
YOU NEXT DEADLINE. FIVE EIGHTY
FIVE EIGHT ZERO. HELLO MY NAME
IS THE NEED CáC HELLO I'M
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT FOR A
THREE EIGHT FIVE ON BEHALF OF
STUDENTS MAKING A CHANGE THANK
YOU THANK YOU. NEXT DEADLINE
SIX OH TWO. HI YES. ANY TROUBLE
BUT NOT YOU CAN TRUST WES IN
STRONG FIVE THANK YOU. NEXT
DEADLINE FIVE NINETY ONE. HELLO
DALE SHE BUT ON LOOK THAT DATE
COLLEGE. WHERE'D BUT THE COURT
AT EIGHT FIVE THANK. NEXT
DEADLINE TO FORTY ONE. CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES WE CAN GOOD MORNING
MY- NAME IS SHOT. I AM THE ALL
ALL REQUIRED BY MY REYES AND
MEDICAL DEVICE COMPANY- AND
THEN YOU I'M AN AMERICAN LET.
INDIAN INDIAN AMERICAN YEAH- I
RECOMMEND ASSOCIATION OF WOMEN
BUSINESS ALL MEMBERS WE
REPRESENT ONE POINT ONE MILLION.
WOMEN BUSINESS OWNERS ARE YOU
IN SUPPORT ON HIM. APRIL
EIGHTEENTH THANK YOU VERY MUCH
I APOLOGIZE. NEXT DEADLINE SIX
SEVEN NINE. AT SIX HUNDRED NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M CALLING ON
BEHALF OF PEOPLE RIGHT ADVOCATE
IS STRONG SUPPORT AT EIGHTY
EIGHT FIVE THANK YOU. NEXT
DEADLINE SIX FOURTEEN. I'M NOT
I'M NOT A PROBLEM AND I COULD
ONLY A LUBRICATED FIVE BECAUSE
THE COLONY. THANK YOU. NEXT
DEADLINE SIX SEVEN THREE. HELLO.
I'M SORRY I WOULD. I NEED THEM
NOT BEING WE SHOWED UP IT'S A
FIVE BECAUSE EVERYTHING THAT
WOULD. CALL THANK YOU FOR
CALLING. MAC THE FIND FOR
TWENTY SEVEN. FIND FOUR TWENTY
SEVEN. YOU HAVE YOUR MEAT ON.
Là M<c.cyan> TO THE NEXT ONE THAT</c>
PLAN ONE SIXTY SEVEN. HELLO
MISSION MANAGERS SAY I'M COMING
FROM CENTRAL CALIFORNIA I'LL BE
HOW ALL OF CENTRAL. PARK
FALLING ON A SOCIAL ATTORNEY.
AND JOHN H. CAT IS ANYTHING IN
THE FILE THANK YOU. NEXT
DEADLINE. TO SIXTY EIGHT. I
LOVE WITH ME. YES OKAY GOOD
MORNING CONNECTION WELL EIGHTY
OF WANNA AND JOHNNY OPPORTUNITY
EIGHTY FIVE EIGHT EIGHT AFTER
THAT YOUR YOUR COMMUNICATION.
SURE I CAN I AM HE WILL MOVE ON
TO MY- IF YOU. ECONOMY GOT. THE
NIGHT AFFECT THE PEOPLE ORDER
OR VISION ON YOU COULD CALL
BACK LATER IN OPPOSITION PLEASE.
NEXT DEADLINE SIX TWENTY FIVE.
HI THIS IS DONNAI'LL DOWN- I'M
A UC BERKELEY GRADUATE I
CALLING YOU EXPRESSED MY SUPER
SUPPORT BY EIGHTY EIGHT FIVE
THANK YOU THANK YOU. THE NEXT
DEADLINE. FIVE SEVENTY EIGHT.
THIS IS THE KIND OF ONE ACTION
I ONLY USE A FEW A FINE. THANK
YOU. NEXT DEADLINE SIX HUNDRED.
YEAH BUT I MEAN IT LINE SIX
HUNDRED. WILL MOVE TO THE NEXT
ONE LINE SIX TWENTY SIX. GO
AHEAD LINE SIX TWENTY SIX. WHAT
ARE THE NEXT ONE AT SIX TWENTY
EIGHT. BY THE TWENTY EIGHTH YOU
HAVE THIS I'M IN. ON TO THE
NEXT ONE. NINETY SIX THIRTY
WHAT. MY NAME IS NINA AND I AM
NOT. GREAT GREAT AND I.
EIGHTEEN I THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NEXT DEADLINE TO SIXTY TWO.
YEAH I MEAN IT TO THE TABLE. ON
TO THE NEXT ONE NOT MUCH SIX
THIRTY FOUR. HI MY NAME IS
WHICH WAS SOMETHING THERE AND I
AM AND ASIAN AMERICAN PARENT
LIVING IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
AND PART OF A COALITION
REPRESENTING OVER FOUR HUNDRED
AND FIFTY ORGANIZATIONS THE
PARTY IF YOU FIVE NINE APART.
THANK YOU. NEXT DEADLINE SIX
THIRTY SIX. MORNING MR CHERRY
MEMBERS CRISTINA MARCELLA ON
BEHALF THE ONE THAT THE ASIAN
FOR COLLEGE ADMISSION
COUNSELING IS DRUNK BEFORE.
THANK YOU. NEXT TIME. SIX FORTY
SIX. HI MY NAME PUT THE MEALS
FROM MAKING THE CALIFORNIA AND
I'M A STRONG SUPPORT OF PCA.
THANK YOU. NEXT DEADLINE SIX
FORTY NINE. I'M LATE OR EVEN
THOUGHT EIGHT- PHONE. SO AND
I'M GONNA BUT IT BY BEING THANK
YOU. NEXT DEADLINE SIX FIFTY
EIGHT. NOW WITH SIX FIVE EIGHT
IF I HAD. I CAN'T GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS LINDA BE. I'M I WORK ON
THE HOUSE ON THE COALITION
CALIFORNIA AND I- FONG FORGET
BPA FIVE THANK YOU. NEXT IN
LINE ONE THIRTY FIVE. I HAD
NINE ONE THIRTY FIVE. KEVIN I'M
HERE. AHMED BUT NOT. IN FIND
OUT WHAT WELL YOU NEED EIGHT.
EIGHT WE HAVE BUT IF YOU CAN
WHAT WILL WHAT WILL LOOK TO
WILL. HELLO MY NAME NOBODY. YOU
GOING WELL HAVE A MUCH ONE OF
ONE CREATE. THE NAME. WHEN I
FEEL I MODERATE GOING. BOB
HERTZBERG TO MOVE TO THE NEXT
ONE UP. SIX FIFTY TWO. HELLO
YES WE AT. MY NAME IS JOHN I'M
SANTIAGO I'VE ONLY A POST
EIGHTY EIGHT FIVE YOU COULD
CALL BACK AFTER ME THANK YOU.
WHAT A LINE. SIXTY SEVEN. THAT
WAS MY. ONE SIX SEVEN. HELLO
I'M SHAYANNA SILICON FELIZ
CENTRAL CALIFORNIA CHINESE
CONTRA OF ASSOCIATE ACOSTA JOHN
ONLY THE ONLY CHANCE. IF YOU
THIS FAR THANK YOU. NEXT
DEADLINE SIXTY TWO. KEVIN SAMIR
AT SIXTY TWO. I AM SIXTY TWO
THE HAT. BUT THE NEXT ONE LINE
FIVE WELL. GO AHEAD NINE FIVE
TWELVE YEAH BUT THE MUTE. ON
THE TO THE NEXT ONE OF MINE SIX
THIRTY ELEVEN IN CAN THE LAKE
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS ERIC
PAIN AND I'M A TRUSTEE WITH THE
STATE IN OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT- AND- PRESIDENT OF
THAT CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGE- BLACK COCKPIT CALLING
IN STRONG SUPPORT- EIGHTY EIGHT
FIVE. THANK YOU THANK YOU. NEXT
DEADLINE I'M. THIRTY FIVE. OUT
ONE FIVE CHECK IT ME UP. ON THE
NEXT ONE MY SIX EIGHTY NINE.
NINE EIGHT EIGHT NINE YEAH YEAH.
HI MY NAME IS NATALIE WE ALL
NEED TO LEARN AND I ATE A
RESIDENT OF SOUTH SAN FRANCISCO
AND I'M IN STRONG SUPPORT AS A
YOU SEE A FIVE. THANK YOU. NEXT
DEADLINE SIX SIXTY THREE. AT
SIX SIXTY THREE I HAVE. YOU
HAVE A MEDIA. ON THE NEXT ONE
LINE SIX NINETY THREE. NINE SIX
NINETY EIGHT YEAH I MEAN IF. ON
THE NEXT ONE LINE TWO THIRTY
FIVE. YOUR TO MORE ILLEGAL AND
YOU GOT. I KNOW YOU SHRINK.
YOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE
MINUTE TO THE NEXT ONE LINE SIX
SEVENTY NINE. HI THIS IS THE
ONE WHO. FROM ANY ANGLE I'M
STRONGLY AGAINST ME THANK YOU
MA'AM BROUGH TOWARDS TAKING
SUPPORT RIGHT NOW IF YOU MAY
CALL BACK. NEXT DEADLINE SIX
SIXTY TWO. I AND I CAN SIX THE
TWO. THEY HAVE UP WELCOME AT
THE NEXT NINE. X. SIXTY WHAT.
THE MONEY SENATORS AND MANAGE
GREATLY FROM THE CITY OF
CONFLICT. THE ITEM THAT
PREVENTED CENTRAL CALIFORNIA
CHINESE CULTUE ASSOCIATION WE
ARE STRONGLY OPPOSED TO EIGHTY
NINE WE'RE TAKING SUPPORT RIGHT
NOW. YOU MAY CALL BACK AFTER
ALL I THINK YEAH SURE. THANK
YOU. MAX LINE. TO EIGHT. GO
AHEAD NINE HUNDRED NAME. CHECK
COMMUNITY. ARE GONNA MOVE ON
THE LINE SIX NINETY ONE. YEAH
IN. HELLO AND HAPPY.
ONE MOMENT
WHILE I LOOK AT IT MY NUMBER.
NINE FIVE OR SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
LATEST ONLINE UNIVERSE I'LL
CALL YOU THAT. CALLING EACH OR
AT EIGHT AT. THANK YOU. PLAN
FOR SIXTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. AND NINE
FOUR SIX FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YOU MAY BE ON MUTE. MOVING ON
TO THE LINE FIVE TWENTY EIGHT.
MINE FIVE TWENTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ANNIE MARTIN ON BEHALF OF
EQUALITY CALIFORNIA IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU AND NINE
FIVE SIXTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE FIVE
SIXTY TWO YOU MAY BE ON MUTE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
ALEX NINE THOUSANDS. OF OUR
GRAND I'M GOING INSURANCE FOR
THE STATE. THANK YOU CAN LINE
FOR SEVENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE FOUR
SEVENTY FIVE YOU MAY BE ON MUTE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. AND MOVING ON
TO THE LINE. FIVE FORTY FOUR
ONE FIVE FORTY FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME WHICH MY NAME
IS REGINA. EIGHT FIVE LEFT
RETURNING ACTUALLY FOR PEACE
AND FREEDOM TEMPERATURES
PROGRAM. FROM THE PORT THANK
YOU. YEAH. NEXT DEADLINE. SIX
EIGHTY SIX EIGHT ZERO. CHECK IT
OUT. IN RANDOM ACT IN THE NEXT
LINE NOT MINE SEVEN ELEVEN.
WELL. YEAH ASSEMBLY LINE. EIGHT
EIGHT FIVE THE WAY A MODEL. BOB
TWENTY ONE THANK YOU ALL MOVE
ON MARTY. I LOVE THAT LINE FIVE
FIFTEEN AT THE END. THE GUY HAD.
FIVE FIFTEEN AND MILLION. THE
MOMENT IN THE NINE ONE NOT MINE
SEVEN EIGHTEEN. HI MY NAME IS
OUT THERE ARE RIGHT. YOU WILL
LET THEM- BUT THE CAR. WHO OUR
SUPPORT EIGHTY FIVE THANK YOU
THANK YOU. NEXT DEADLINE SEVEN
TWENTY TWO. YOU HAVE A TIME IN
MIND SEVEN TWENTY TWO. HI MY
NAME IS BOTH VERY DOWN- I'M
CALLING FROM MUCH BETTER AMONG
THE CALIFORNIA I STRONGLY
SUPPORT EIGHTY EIGHT. EIGHTY
EIGHT FIVE THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NEXT DEADLINE FOR NINETY TWO.
GO AHEAD FOR NINETY TWO. ONE OF
THE NEXT ONE THAT NINE SEVEN
SIXTEEN. SEVEN ONE SIX. HELLO
AMY WE CAN HEAR YEAH. HEY YEAH
I'M A DANIELLE BUT MIGHT BE
WITH THE- OP STARTED- OPPOSED
TO EIGHTY FIVE TO BE THANK YOU
THANK YOU. NEXT HEADLINE SEVEN
TWENTY EIGHT. HI MY NAME IS
DAISY THOMAS CALLING FROM THE
CITY OF ANAHEIM CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU. NEXT
DEADLINE SEVEN TWENTY FOUR. HI
HI MY NAME IS THE MAIN PROBLEM
OF A STRONG OPPOSE THEY SAY
FIVE OR TAKING SUPPORT RIGHT
NOW PLEASE CALL BACK. NEXT
DEADLINE SEVEN TWENTY THREE.
THE MORNING SENATORS MY NAME
THE POSH TO- REPRESENTING TEN
THOUSAND PEOPLE IN CHINESE
COMMUNITY WE STRONGLY OPPOSED
TO EIGHT WERE TAKING SIDEBOARD
CALLS RIGHT NOW MA'AM PLEASE
CALL BACK. NEXT DEADLINE SEVEN
THIRTY SIX. ONE WELL- ACCORDING
TO BIG BODY BECAUSE THEY WERE
TAKING SUPPORT NUMBER OF THOSE
IN SUPPORT PLEASE BE ON THIS
CALL NOT OPPOSITION YOU'LL HAVE
THAT OPPORTUNITY IN A FEW
MINUTES. THESE ARE ONLY SUPPORT
CALLS. PLEASE PROCEED IMPACT
WATER LINE. ONLINE SIX NINETY
EIGHT. YOU HAVE ASSEMBLY AT SIX
NINETY EIGHT. OKAY. NINETY
EIGHT AND MY ENEMIES BALLOT
FROM IN DETAIL I JOHN YELLED
WELL THESE FOUR EIGHT FORT ONLY.
THANK YOU MOVE ON PLEASE
MODERATOR. ACCESS LINE FORTY
TWO. HI LINDA CAMARO WITH THAT
THE CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC
HEALTH NETWORK IN VERY STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NEXT DEADLINE SEVEN FORTY SEVEN.
WHENEVER THE- I AM THE LAWS
NUMBERS THIS CRAP AMERICA JERRY
ARMORS AND I CERTAINLY SUPPORT
A LOT THANK YOU. ACCESSED SEVEN
FORTY FIVE. BE RIGHT WITH THAT
THE ARE YOU CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF EIGHTY FIVE
THANK YOU THANK YOU. NEXT
TWENTY FOUR. I CAN MORNING I'M
TEARING DOWN FROM THIRTY IF
THAT NUMBER I'M STRONGLY
OPPOSING ETIENNE FIVE AQ
IMPROVE IN SUPPORT PAYS ONLY
MOVE WHEN YOU'RE NOT A
MODERATOR. NEXT. TO THIRTY TWO.
NINE TEN TO THIRTY TALE. YOU
HAVE IT ON MUTE. BOB GOT IN AN
ACT. ONE NINE SEVEN FORTY
EIGHT. WE WERE IN THE CLUB. THE
MOTEL EXTRANJERO COLD THIS IS
FOR SUPPORT ONLY MA'AM PLEASE
CALL BACK. SO ALL THOSE ON THIS
LINE SHOULD BE FOR SUPPORT ONLY
FOR A CA FIVE THE OPPOSITION
WILL HAVE THEIR OPPORTUNITY
SHORTLY. ACCESS LINE SEVEN
FIFTY EIGHT. BY AT SEVEN FIFTY
EIGHT. YOU HAVE A COMMENT. WHAT
ARE THE NEXT LINE. SEVEN FIFTY
NINE. YOU HAVE A MEETING AT
SEVEN FIFTY NINE. HI MEDINA WE
WITH- WHICH WOULD CHIRLA
COALITION FOR HUMANE IMMIGRANT
RIGHTS AND WE ARE AT THE CORE
OF EIGHTY FIVE THANK YOU. THE
WAY WE DO NOT HAVE ANYONE ELSE
Q. AND SUPPORT AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU- THANK YOU MODERATOR
WOULD YOU PLEASE JUST OPEN THE
LINES ONE MORE TIME JUST TO.
PROMPT THEM AGAIN TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE THERE ALSO IN
SUPPORT THAT HAS NOT HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
YEAH AT THE- END SUPPORT HAVE
NOT. SPOKEN YET PLEASE PRESS
ONE. ZERO AT THAT I AM. NOW
WHAT BUT APPLY AND WHY DON'T
NINE. HI MY NAME IS SERRA
BANCROFT DIDN'T ELECTED SENATOR
AN UNDERGRADUATE UNIT UC
BERKELEY AND I'M CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF EIGHTY EIGHT
FIVE. THANK YOU. NEXT DEADLINE
FORTY ONE. UHHUH. YEAH BUT I
MEAN. ONE MOMENT WHILE THE
NUMBER. NEXT WE WILL HAVE A
TIME LINE FOR SEVENTY FIVE.
FOUR SEVEN. YEAH BUT WE CAN'T.
ACTUALLY THE LONG BOND
EXPLAINED. FIVE SIXTY FOUR. HI
THIS IS FRENCH LAW WITH THE
THIRTY OF UC DAVIS WE ARE PROUD
TO ANNOUNCE THAT WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY FIVE. THANK
YOU YEAH NEXT CALL THAT A LINE
FIVE FORTY FIVE. NINE FIVE
FORTY FIVE ARE YOU AT. WE WANT
TO THE NEXT ONE. NINE FIVE
TWENTY THREE. GOOD MORNING
SENATORS MY NAME IS CAROL CAN
CRITICAL DIRECTOR OF THE SAN
DIEGO COUNTY BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL AND
I'M CALLING IN TO THINK THAT WE
ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT AND A CA
FIVE THANK YOU THANK YOU
MODERATOR WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
TO END OUR TELECONFERENCE
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT WE HAVE
THREE WITNESSES IN OUR HEARING
ROOM TWENTY FORTY THAT WE WILL
GO TO. TO COMPLETE OUR ONE HOUR
OF TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT SO IF
WE COULD GO TO ROOM TWENTY
FORTY FOUR PUBLIC TESTIMONY
PLEASE. GOOD MORNING. HI MY
NAME IS KIM MA'AM SO I'M HERE
REPRESENTING A DOES SACRAMENTO.
I'M IN STRONG SUPPORT AND AC
EIGHT BY BANK YOU. CHRIS LAST
IN EIGHTY WAS A CRIMINAL EIGHTY
WAS CALIFORNIA EIGHTY WAS
ASSEMBLY STRONG STRONG STRONG
SUPPORT OF ACA FIABLE YES THANK
YOU. IN. KAREN SOMEBODY BY
REPRESENTING THE EDUCATION
TRUST WEST WE HER IN SUPPORT
ASKING YOU TO ASK LET THE
VOTERS DECIDE ON FAIRNESS AND
EQUITY THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THE TEST WITH THAT DOES
CONCLUDE OUR WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT FOR THOSE WHO WERE NOT
ABLE TO TESTIFY AND ARE STILL
ON THE TELECONFERENCE LINE
PLEASE. RECOGNIZE AND
UNDERSTAND THAT YOU CAN SUBMIT
IN WRITING OR CALL THE
COMMITTEE OFFICE AND- STATE
YOUR POSITION THROUGH THAT-
THAT- OPPORTUNITY AND VEHICLE.
TO HAVING HEARD FROM ALL
SUPPORTERS WE WILL NOW FOLLOW
THE SAME PROCESS IN HERE FROM
OPPOSITION WITNESSES WE DO HAVE
TO PRINCIPLE OPPOSITION
WITNESSES. THEY WILL BE GIVEN A
TOTAL OF THREE MINUTES BETWEEN
THE TWO WE HAVE CRYSTAL LIU ON
THE LINE. THANK YOU MY NAME IS
CRYSTAL LOW I AM THE PRESIDENT
OF SILICON VALLEY CHINESE
ASSOCIATION FOUNDATION. MARTY
YOU ONE SECOND AND THIS ONE
HUNDRED TWELVE. THIS NEW ONE
SECOND PLEASE I'M SORRY TO
INTERRUPT YOU AND I APPRECIATE
YOUR STARTING SO THE PROMPTLY.
HELLO CAN I SPEAK NOW.
MODERATOR IF YOU COULD TAKE
THOSE WHO WERE IN THE QUEUE FOR
SUPPORT AND PUT THEM BACK INTO
THE GENERAL HUGH- WE WOULD
APPRECIATE IT. THANK YOU. YOU
LIKE THEM REMOVED FROM THE
KI<c.cyan>. AND FOR THOSE OF STORY</c>
OF MISIRLOU AND THE AND WE HAVE
FRANK AS SUIT TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TOTAL THREE MINUTES-
THE SALUTE PLEASE THE PLEASE
PROCEED AGAIN MY APOLOGIES. OH
NO PROBLEM YES- I AM PUSH THAT
AND CRYSTAL LIU PRESIDENT OF
SILICON VALLEY CHINESE
ASSOCIATION FOUNDATION. I SPEAK
FOR THE MORE THAN ONE HUNDRED
AND TWELVE THOUSAND INDIVIDUAL.
WHO HAD SIGNED OUR PETITION
OPPOSING THE EFFORT. TO REPEAL
PROPOSITION TWO OH NINE.
PROPOSITION TWO OH NINE PROTECT
US ALL. THE WORDS OF IT
OPERATIVE CLAUSE ARE CLEAR AND
I QUOTE THE STATE SHALL NOT
DISCRIMINATE AGAINST. OR GRANT
PREFERENTIAL TREATMENT TO ANY
INDIVIDUAL OR GROUP ON THE
BASIS OF RACE SEX. COLOR
ETHNICITY OR NATIONAL ORIGIN IN
THE OPERATION OF PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT PUBLIC EDUCATION OR
PUBLIC CONTRACTING. THOSE ARE
WORDS THE STATE SOMETHING
FUNDAMENTAL ABOUT WHO WE ARE AS
AMERICANS. MILLION HAVE RISKED
THEIR LIVES TO COME TO THE
COUNTRY THAT SEEKS TO JUDGE IF
PEOPLE NOT BY THEIR SKIN COLOR
BUT BY THE CONTENT. OF THEIR
CHARACTER IN RECENT YEARS THERE
HAVE AND THEY HAVE COME FROM-CHINA FROM ETHIOPIA FROM INDIA
RUSSIA SALVADOR NIKON FULL OF
HOPE THAT THEY WILL BE JUDGED
ON THEIR MERITS NOT ON THEIR
WEIGHT BUT NOW EIGHTY FIVE ONE
YOU TAKE THAT. TO ADD YOUR TO
THE FIRE OF I DIDN'T HOW. THEY
NATION IS IN THE MIDST OF A
GLOBAL PANDEMIC AS WELL AS A
SOCIAL UP PEOPLE. IN THE COMING
WEEKS MANY MISTAKES WILL BE
MADE MISTAKE THAT WILL BE
REGRETTED FURTHER DOWN THE
ROAD. DON'T LET THIS BE ONE OF
THEM. CHEAP DISCRIMINATION
ILLEGAL. NO ON A FEW FIVE THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISS
LOU MR DO. THANK YOU SENATOR MY
NAME IS FRENCH YOU ON THE CO
FOUNDER AND YOU ALWAYS HAVE
LIKE A SLIGHT QUALITY. EIGHTY
FIVE IS LOOKING PRETTY TRADING
THE PEOPLE BANQUET TRAPS TO
ENSURE THAT ALL CALIFORNIANS
ARE TREATED EQUALLY REGARDLESS
OF THEIR GREAT THAT ALL THAT
COULD BE. AT HAND. IN FACT THIS
IS A START TOWARDS VERY PLEASED
POLITICS BY THE CALIFORNIA
STATE. IT IS FIFTH SENATE
RACISM BY EFFECTIVE MISSION
RIGHT TACKLE DEFINITION.
SENATORS YOUR AGENDA TODAY ONLY
TAKING SUPPORTING THE FOR FIRST
OURS IS STRONGLY BIASED AGAINST
OPPOSITION FIVE. EIGHT ANOTHER
SAMPLE OF HISPANIC OPERATION OF
DETENTION VOICES IN CALIFORNIA.
AND THE SENATOR HAS BEEN FOR
WITH WELL BECAUSE ACT ON THE
COMMISSION SHOWING THAT
PROPOSITION TWO AND ON HAS BEEN
BENEFICIAL FOR ALL. UC SYSTEM
WHITE STUDENTS WHO ARE NOW ONLY
ACCOUNT FOR TWENTY FOUR PROJECT
THE CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
HOW THE STUDENT BODY THAT IS
NEARLY 75% OF PEOPLE OF COLOR.
PROTRUSION SHOW NINE ALSO A
FISCAL SUCCESS. ON DIVERSE
CITY. AND ANOTHER IMPORTANT
IMPORTANT POINT TO ADD IT BACK
PROPOSITION TWO OH NINE DOES
NOT PREVENT THE STATE FROM
PRACTICING SOCIAL ECONOMIC
BASED AFFIRMATIVE ACTION. WE
ALL FOR IT TO HELP THOSE PEOPLE
YOU MEET. REGARDLESS OF THEIR
SKIN COLOR AND REYES THANK YOU
MISTER STERLING I'M SORRY I
HAVE TO. I HAVE TO STOP YOUR
TESTIMONY YOU'VE SUCCEEDED THE
THREE MINUTES- BY SOME SO WE
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO THOSE IN
OPPOSITION. WHO ARE HERE IN THE
GALLERY WOULD YOU LIKE TO SPEAK.
IF YOU ARE IN THE GALLERY IN
LIKE TO SPEAK PLEASE GO TO THE
MICROPHONE AND SHARE YOUR- YOUR
THOUGHTS AND YOU CAN. PLEASE
LET US KNOW YOUR- NAME YOUR
AFFILIATION AND YOUR POSITION
ON THE ACA AND THAT WOULD DO IT
AND I WILL THEN BEGIN THE ONE
HOUR TIMER FOR THOSE SPEAKING
HERE TODAY. EITHER ON THE
TELECONFERENCE OR IN PERSON IN
OPPOSITION. YOU CAN STAND AT
THE MICROPHONE AND PLEASE BEGIN
WITH NAME. AFFILIATION THANK
YOU. OKAY MY NAME IS QUESTION I
AM AS A WOMAN IN COLOR. I
STRONGLY OPPOSE AZ EIGHTY FIVE.
I THINK- AC FIVE OPENS THE DOOR
DENTAL BUT YOU WE ARE ONLY
TAKING TESTIMONY OF YOUR NAME
AND WHATEVER YOU'RE AFFILIATED
WITH AND YOUR POSITION SO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. MOVING ON TO THE
NEXT ANYONE ELSE IN THE GALLERY
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
TO A CA FIVE PLEASE. PROCEED TO
THE- TO THE MICROPHONE. MY NAME
IS LEON FROM EL DORADO HILLS
AND I'M NOT THEN YOU KNOW THREE
OF MY KIDS AND I'M STRONG UPSET
THE AC A FINE THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE THIS MORNING. HI I'M
LUCIA I'M FROM BERKELEY A
STRONGLY OPPOSE. A THE EIGHTY
FIVE THANK YOU. YOU SEE ME. MY
NAME IS AT THE FUNDS I'M A
PARENTS- FOR THE- COLLEGE
STUDENTS AND TWO YEARS AGO MY
AND BUILT THIS APPLYING FOR
YOUR SEATS OR REJECT BECAUSE
SHE'S ASIAN STILL I AM STILL
POLICIES AND HE'S A SEE A. FIVE
HE'S A GOOD STUDENT REJECTED BY
THE- THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
THE GALLERY THESE FOR TO THE
ISIS THANK YOU. HI MY NAME IS A
JUDGE ON THE WRONG SIDE. OF A
HILL AND CLOSE OF AC EIGHTY
FIVE THANK YOU. ANYWHERE ELSE
IN OPPOSITION PLEASE GO TO THE
MICROPHONE HERE IN THE GALLERY
IF NOT WE WILL MOVE TO ROOM
TWENTY FORTY IS THERE ANYONE IN
THE ROOM TWENTY FORTY SPEAKING
IN OPPOSITION. SIR PLEASE THANK
YOU. HI MY NAME IS JOHN WHY AM
I RIGHT TODAY IN COMICAL-
SACRAMENTO COUNTY I STRONGLY
OPPOSE ACA BY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR TESTIMONY TODAY.
AND FOR BEING HERE IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. WE WILL NOW MOVE
TO WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
WAITING TO TESTIFY VIA
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS I'M SORRY
SIR YES PLEASE. HI MY NAME IS
JACK WE AND I'M A YOU STILL A
STUDENT AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
IT'S A FIVE THANK YOU. THANK
MONNING SENATORS MY NAME IS
JUDGE SIMON COME FROM BRENTWOOD
CALIFORNIA. I AM- YOU KNOW
READING MY FAMILY WITH THREE
KIDS GOING TO COLLEGE SOON. AND
I CAN I ALSO REPRESENT ALL TRUE
BELIEVERS SOUTH DR MARTIN
LUTHER KING WAS SAYS. EVERYBODY
SHOULD BE JUDGED BY. STE YOU
KNOW THE CHARACTER CONTENT OF
CHARACTERS BUT NOT BY THE COLOR
OF SKIN. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SIR I APPRECIATE YOUR BEING
HERE ANYONE ELSE IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY WISHING TO SPEAK. IN
OPPOSITION SEEING NO ONE WILL
NOW MOVE TO THE WITNESSES
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO THE
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS. MODERATOR
IF YOU WOULD PLEASE PROMPT THE
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION OF AC A FIVE THEN
WE WILL BEGIN. AND WHEN YOU
HAVE A ROUGH NUMBER OF THOSE
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
IF YOU WOULD LET ME KNOW I
APPRECIATE IT. WE HAVE A
HUNDRED AND NINE IN THE QUEUE
WAITING. VERY GOOD THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND OF REMINDER FOR
EVERYONE SO THAT WE CAN HEAR AS
MANY OF YOU AS POSSIBLE PLEASE
GIVE US YOUR NAME YOUR
AFFILIATION AND YOUR POSITION
ON A CA FIVE AND THEN- WE WILL
MOVE ON TO AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE WE HAVE. ABOUT FIFTY
SIX MINUTES LEFT OF OPPOSITION-
TIME AND- WE WILL HOLD TO THAT-
PLEASE- MATTER MODERATOR PLEASE
BEGIN. AND IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME IF YOU ALREADY ARE IN THE
QUEUE. WE. WILL TAKE YOUR NAME
ARE YOUR NUMBER. AND OUR FIRST
SPEAKER TODAY ON. OPPOSITION IS
MINE TWO HUNDRED AND SIXTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE MOMENT.
IT'LL BE JUST A BRIEF MOMENT
LONGER THAT'S OKAY WE'RE WE'VE
STOP THE TIMER. MAIN. HE. MAN
MAN MAN. HE. UHHUH UHHUH UHHUH
UHHUH. YEAH. MAN. NAME YEAH.
HELLO. MODERATOR IS THERE A-
SOMEONE ON THE LINE. NINE TWO
SIX IS OPEN. HELLO CAN YOU HEAR
ME YES. THIS IS HEADLINE FROM
LOS ANGELES I AM STRONGLY
OPTION- UP EIGHT EIGHT FIVE AND
I'M I'M BEHALF OF WILL NOT TRY
EIGHTEEN FEDERATION WE ALL
STRONGLY OPPOSE THE EIGHTY FIVE
THANK YOU THANK YOU. NEXT
DEADLINE TO FOURTEEN. MIND
FOURTEEN. WILL MOVE ON TO THE
NEXT LINE. NINE ONE FORTY ONE.
NINE ONE FORTY ONE. MY MOM AND.
ARE YOU MOVING ON TO THE NEXT
ONE'S A MODERATOR OR. YES ONE
MOMENT.
HERE COLLEGE AT THE
TELLING. FIND FOR FORTY NINE.
MY THIRTEEN YEAR LINE IS.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. WELL GOOD
MORNING ONLY. GOOD MORNING MY
NAME. WHEN ISRAELI BONTA
CHANGES I YOU SEE AT A GLANCE.
I WITH THEM TO MY FAMILY. AND I
JUST OPPOSE. EIGHT A FIVE THANK
YOU. NINE ONE TWENTY EIGHT YEAH
NINE IS A. NINE ONE TWENTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. AND
MOVING ON TO MINE. FIVE
FOURTEEN. NINE FIVE FOURTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO YOU TO ME. YES.
OKAY GOOD AT THE MALL GOT A
MONEY THING IT HAS. OUR DATA
THAT PETER FRANCO BUT YOU KNOW.
WRONG BECOMING A- RIVER THAT
EIGHT HIGH AT THE. STRONGLY
OPPOSE TO EIGHT EIGHT FIVE
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR. NINE
ONE THIRTY NINE YOUR LINE IS A.
MY NAME ONE THIRTY NINE PLEASE
CHECK YOUR MUTE. AND MOVING AND
ONLINE ONE OF. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
IN MY NO NO SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. PLEASE GO AHEAD. MOVING
ON THE LINE ONE TWENTY ONE.
LINE ONE TWENTY ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. PLEASE GO AHEAD. THREE
TEN NINE ONE FORTY FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINE ONE FORTY FOUR. PLEASE
CHECK YOUR MUTE BUTTON YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. NINE FOUR FORTY
FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD.
NINE FOUR FORTY FOUR.
NINE FOUR EIGHTY TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HELLO CAN ONE. PLEASE.
HI MY NAME IS JAMES I'M CALLING
FROM GOD I I'M A COMPLETE YOUR
OF AND ENGINE BAO AND ALSO
HAPPEN AND THEN YOU WILL COME
BAR OF THE AND THE OF AMERICAN
LAWYER OF THE DAY AREA I'M
SORRY THING TO A YOUNG HEY THE
EIGHT AND SO HE NEVER GOT HOW
WITHOUT HAVE SHOWN THAT WE ARE
A BILL A STATE BY THE VERY MUCH
MA'AM. YEAH LINE IS OPEN. HE.
LIVING UNTIL LIKE ONE FIFTY
EIGHT. LINE ONE FIFTY EIGHT
YOUR MIND IS OPEN. HI SB YEAH.
PRODUCT ANYWAY- SO I'M PUTTING
YOU ON HOLD BY THE- THANK YOU.
A LINE FIVE FORTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE FIVE
HUNDRED AND FORTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE CHECK ME BUTTON.
AND LIVING ON THE LINE FIVE
NINETY FOUR. NINE FIVE NINETY
FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME
FIND FONG AND I'M- WHEN I AM
REPRESENTING THE CULTURE ANY OF
BREAKING BOUNDARY CLUB APPLE
CLUB AND SET UP. FIND THEY HIDE
WHO THAT'S ONLY OPPOSED DATE
BACK. THANK YOU. NEXT SLIDE SIX
FORTY SEVEN. JENNIFER MUTE SIX
FORTY SEVEN. HELLO YES GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS RACHEL FROM UC
SANTA BARBARA THE
COMMUNICATIONS DIRECTOR OF THE
EASY YEAH YEAH THE LOCATION
DIRECTOR OF PUBLIC SPEAKING OF
IRELAND WITH THE OTHER GUYS FOR
TRANSPARENT I'M A LOT OF THE
THEM THAT ANDI STRONG OF EASY
FIVE YEAH. THE YOU. AN ACTOR
LINE. SIX NINE. GO AHEAD SIX
SIXTY NINE DO YOU HAVE IT ON
MUTE. ABANDONED MINING FIFTY
SIX. HELLO YES I HAD AND MAY GO
MORNING CHECK NUMBER MY NAME
FIFTEEN THOUSAND AND FROM THERE
GONNA CITATION FEDERATION I
STRONGLY OPPOSE EIGHT EIGHT
FIVE THANK YOU THANK YOU. NEXT
IN LINE AT ONE TWENTY THREE. HI
BONNIE MY NAME HI QUESTION I'M
A BOARD MEMBER ONE OF THE HIGH
NEED AND MARTIN EVERY
PUBLICATION I ONLY HOPE EIGHTY
FIVE TOTALLY UNFAIR FOR
BUILDING WHAT CAUGHT WILL
DAMAGE THE QUALITY OF OUR. HE
WILL NOT THANK YOU FOR MUCH FOR
THE- NEXT THE SET. SIX I'M
GOING COULD I'M PLAY FROM TITAN
CAN I'M NOT MORE CREATIVE NO
AND I'M THE PEOPLE COLOR AND
APART OF HI THAT EIGHT NOT
THOSE. AND GAIN OVER A HUNDRED
EIGHTY TOO MANY MEN WILL
PARTICIPATE IN THETO THEY'VE-
80% SAY NOW LOOK ANYTHING NEED
TO YOU CAN. AND BY NOW A STATE
THANK YOU THANK YOU. NEXT THE
FAR FOR THREE. FOR THREE. ARE
YOU ANYA. WILL MOVE TO THE NEXT.
ONE NINE SIX FORTY TWO. LITTLE
EIGHTEEN FROM EVERGREEN CHINESE
AMERICAN ASSOCIATION IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO A CA FIVE THANK
YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY. NEXT DEADLINE FIVE
FIFTY FOUR. WELL HELLO I HAD.
YES MY NAME IN THE MAN ABOUT
YOUNG I'M ONLY GONNA AYE ASIAN
FEDERAL MISTY EYED DOWN A
COUPLE AB A FINE THANK YOU
THANK YOU. ACCESS. NINETY TWO.
AT SIX NINETY TWO. YES MY NAME
IS JENNIFER GO. AND IF THEY
SENT- FROM GOTTA GO THANK YOU
CAPTION EIGHT THEN KAREN. ASIAN
YES YONGE OPPOSITION. TO EIGHTY
EIGHT. THANK YOU. NEXT DEADLINE.
SIX EIGHTEEN SIX EIGHT ZERO.
HELLO HELLO YES GOOD MORNING.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS SHANE
I'M I'M FROM SAN DIEGO I
REPRESENT- A GROUP OF ATTENDED
MOM WITHDRAWN OPPOSE A TO FIVE
BECAUSE THAT IS A FILE BILL
WILL BE BY THE CALIFORNIA INTO
I'M I CALLING FROM THANK YOU
MA'AM WE HEARD YOUR OR ANYTHING
YOU MOVE ON PLEASE MY. NEXT
DEADLINE SEVEN FIFTY THE. SEVEN
FIVE ZERO. YEAH BUT THE MUTE
SEVEN FIFTY. YEAH AND IF YOU
LOOK AT ME YES WITH WITH- YEAH
THIS IS JESSICA SONG FROM CHINO
HILLS I'M STRONGLY OPPOSED IF
EIGHTY FIVE. THANK YOU. NEXT
DEADLINE. FIVE OH NINE. FIVE
HUNDRED NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YOU HAVE A COMMENT. WILL MOVE
TO THE NEXT LINE. SEVEN TWENTY
SEVEN TWO ZERO. HELLO HELLO MY
AT. YEAH MY NAME EVERY MALL
EVERY. DAY THEY BOTH IF IT FIVE
THANK YOU THANK YOU. NEXT
DEADLINE SIX HUNDRED PLEASE GO
AHEAD. LINE SIX HUNDRED. YOU
HAVE A TIME YOU. ALLOW ME YES
YES YES. HELLO GOOD MORNING
MISTER SPEAKER AND A MEMBRANE
MY NAME YOU CAN I'M FROM SAN
JOSE I JOHNNY OPPOSED EIGHTY
EIGHT BY. THANK YOU. NEXT. ONE
SIXTY FIVE. MY AND ONE SIXTY
FIVE YOU HAVE A COMMENT. ONE
SIXTY FIVE. WILL MOVE TO THE
NEXT LINE. LINE ONE EIGHTY NINE.
MY FAMILY I'M CALLING
REPRESENTING OUR ORGANIZATION
EIGHT EIGHT FIVE THE STORY THE
CARD YOU WITH OVER FOUR HUNDRED
AND TWO MEMBERS WE STRONGLY
OPPOSED. EIGHTY EIGHT FIVE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT
DEADLINE. ONE OH NINE HUNDRED
NINE. JAVA SOME NEW TWENTY NINE.
WILL MOVE TO THE NEXT ONE. LINE
ONE NINETY SEVEN. I AM MORNING-
CARE AND MEMBERS- LUCY FAN
COLLEEN FROM PALO ALTO
CALIFORNIA AND THE UC BERKELEY
PHD GRADUATING DAM AND ALSO A
MINORITY WOMEN- I AND ALSO I'M
YOU HAVE A UC BERKELEY TRYING
YOUR LINE RIGHT AFTER THE ASIAN
WE ARE YOU STRONG OPPOSITION TO
EIGHTY EIGHT FIVE BUT NOW THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT
IN LINE FORTHE. SEVEN FIND FOR
THIRTY SEVEN DO YOU HAVE THE
TIME YOU WANT. WILL MOVE TO THE
NEXT ONE THAT'S GOING TO BE
NINE ONE NINETY THREE. HELLO
YES GO HEAD TO LOCATE HIM. IN
ITEM CLOSE ON THAT SANTIAGO I'M
NOT PRESENTED TO CONSCIOUS
CREATION OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
WE HAVE AN I GET MORE THAN
SOUTH ONE THOUSAND PEOPLE YES
JOHN GREEN OPPOSE IT IS A FIVE.
WELL KNOWN THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NEXT DEADLINE SEVEN THIRTY
EIGHT. GOOD MORNING AUDIBLE
JOHN AND I'M THE PRESIDENT OF
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TAIWANESE AMERICANS WITH OVER
THREE THOUSAND FAMILIES WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE ACA FIVE. THANK
YOU. NEXT DEADLINE SIX SEVENTY
NINE. HI THIS IS ONE GOLD CROWN.
FIRST BED DO YOU THINK YANDLE
COUNTY I JOHNNY APPROACH EIGHT
THREE EIGHT. EIGHT YOU CAN
KNOWLEDGE YOU CROSSED NEED HE
BY YOU BE THAT YOU WILL PROTECT
CLOUT THANK YOU. KNOW. NEXT
DEADLINE ONE FIFTY NINE. THE
MORNING SENATOR AND- OUR GM
MEMBERS MY NAME YOU CAN HIDE
DOUBLY IF THE BAY AREA OUR-
COMMUNITY STANDING UP HOLD
EIGHT EIGHT EIGHT FIVE THANK
YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY TODAY. NEXT DEADLINE
FOR TWENTY TWO. NINE FOUR
TWENTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. ARE
YOU ON MUTE. ARE GOING TO MOVE
TO THE NEXT ONE THAT'S GOING TO
BE A LINE FOR SIXTY THAT FOUR
SIX ZERO. MINE FOR SIXTY DO YOU
HAVE A TIME UNIT. WILL MOVE TO
THE NEXT ONE AND NOT AS LINE
FOR SIXTY THREE. MINE FOR SIXTY
THREE ARE YOU ON MUTE. WELCOME
TO THE NEXT ONE THAT LINE FOR
THIRTY FOUR. HI GOOD MORNING.
NEEDING MEMBERS MY NAME IS
RACHEL CAN AND I FINANCE
MANAGER ON OUR TOP LINE AND ALL
FIVE OF THEM ARE SENATE LEADER
AND FOUND- MILLER MIDDLE SCHOOL
ON BEHALF OF ME AND MY FAMILY-
I AM CALLING FROM- EIGHT EIGHT
FIVE. BUT NOW THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. NEXT DEADLINE. EIGHT
TWENTY ONE. HI MY NAME IS LOSE
SOMEONE FROM SACRAMENTO I
STRONGLY OPPOSE EIGHTY EIGHT
FIVE IT DESTROYS MERITOCRACY
AND LEGALIZES GLACIAL BASED IN
THE NATION. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY TO CONNECT. NEXT
DEADLINE. TO THIRTY EIGHT. MY
NAME IS DAN REPRESENTED BE A
TRAIN THREE THOUSAND MEMBERS
LONG THE ACT UP HOLD EIGHT
EIGHT FIVE THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NEXT DEADLINE ONE FIFTY SEVEN.
RIGHT GOOD MORNING MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS CHOOSE
YOUR BILL I'M FROM DALY CITY
CALIFORNIA I AM ASIAN AMERICAN
WORKING MONDAY AND I'M
REPRESENTING OVER FIVE HUNDRED
MINOR MINORITY WORKING MONDAY
IN MY NETWORK LAKE COUNTY
OPPOSED TO EIGHTY EIGHT HIGH
AND I URGE THE COMMITTEE. BY A
MUCH. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY. NEXT. SEVEN EIGHTY
FIVE. NINE SEVEN FIVE. YES WE
CAN. HI MONEY- AND THEN. ORDER
FOR HIGH SCHOOLERS IN ON ON THE
OPPOSED BY THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NEXT A. THIRTY YES BUDGET MY
NAME IS NICK YOUNG. I AM THE
ALONG MY ALL TO USE USE THAN
THEIR GOAL. CURRENTLY I'M GONNA
TRY CHEN MAN ALL. AMERICAN
EAGLE IDEATION I START IN I
REPEAT SEND. THING HUNDRED UP
TO MEMBERS. HI PAUL MY GROUP WE
STRONG OPPOSE A STATE FIVE YOU
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. MAX OF
MINE TO TWENTY SEVEN. HELLO
AGAIN. GO AHEAD BY NOT AND-
YEAH HI IT WOULD GO ON UP THE-
YOU DON'T. THE OVER. YOU THE
FAMILY OF. I YOU SEE THANK YOU
THANK YOU. MAXWELL BUT A LINE
SEVEN THIRTY FOUR THE YOUNG
CHEN. HELLO YEAH I HAD. MY NAME
IS THE TERM YEAH FROM I DROPPED
IT- EIGHT EIGHT FIVE. THANKS
THANK YOU. NEXT DEADLINE EIGHT
THIRTY SEVEN. SOME CALL HER
FIFTY I'M THE PRESIDENT OF
SILICON NINETY WILMA
ASSOCIATION I'M HERE
REPRESENTING MORE THAN FIFTEEN
HUNDRED. ONLY UP HOLDING A
CEASEFIRE THANK YOU THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY TODAY. NEXT
DEADLINE ONE OH TWO. MY MIND
UNTIL YOU HAVE A TIME UNIT. MY
MONO TO. WILL MOVE TO THE NEXT
ONE. NINE ONE FORTY NINE. HELLO
YES I AM MY NAME THREE. SO. I
AM I CAN RALLY CALIFORNIA SO
I'M A WORKING MOM AND- I'M ONLY
AGAINST. EIGHT EIGHTY EIGHT
FIVE. THANK YOU THANK YOU. NEXT
DEADLINE SIX NINETY FOUR. SIX
NINETY FOUR ARE YOU ON MUTE.
WELL MOTOR ACT. ONE NINE SEVEN
EIGHTY NINE. SEVEN EIGHTY NINE
ARE YOU ON MUTE. HELLO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO YES GO AHEAD.
MY NAME IS MAGGIE OUT I- BUT
PERCENT OF MIKE BROCK AND I AM
STRUGGLING HOPE EASY EIGHTY
FIVE. THANK YOU. NEXT DEADLINE
FIVE THIRTY EIGHT. HI GOOD
MORNING AND MY NAME IS COUNTY
I'M CALLING FROM SAN JOSE
CALIFORNIA. ON BEHALF OF THE
ASIAN AMERICAN ENGINEERS IN MY
NEIGHBORHOOD ARE STRONGLY
OPPOSED THEEIGHT ZERO FIVE
IT'S GOING TO DESTROY CLICK A
VALLEY AND ALL COULD YOU CALL
COMMITTEE THAT EQUAL RESULT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. NEXT
DEADLINE TO TWENTY NINE. LINE
TWO TWENTY NINE ARE YOU ON MUTE.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS VICTOR
TREND FROM TRACY REPRESENTING
FIVE THOUSAND MALAYSIAN
STUDENTS AND THE BILL NICE WE
STRONGLY OPPOSED TO THE C. S.
FIVE. EIGHTY FIVE YOU CAN YEARS
LATER YOU MAY FIND YOUR HARDING
HOW. WHAT'S YOUR NEEDED FEEL
QUITE A COMMUNITY AT LEVEL
MODEL JOB BUT IT WILL NOT A
CALL AT ALL. THANK YOU. BACK.
TWENTY AT FOUR TWENTY EIGHT ARE
YOU AND MANAGE. NINE FOUR
TWENTY EIGHT. COMMENT TO THE
NEXT ONE LINE FIVE FIFTEEN.
YEAH AND THAT LEAH PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE FIVE FIFTEEN. YEAH
AND THE ONLY A. MOMENT TO THE
NEXT ONE LINE SIX EIGHTY SEVEN.
LINE SIX EIGHTY SEVEN ARE YOU
ON MUTE. HI IT WAS MAINLY YOUNG.
I'M A MOM AGAINST JUDGING BY%
TWENTY THREE AND ME PLEASE VOTE
NO ON A CA FIVE. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY TODAY. NEXT
DEADLINE TO EIGHT. TWO HUNDRED
AIN'T ARE YOU ON MUTE. TWO
HUNDRED NAME. MOMENT TO THE
NEXT. ONE FOR NINETY THREE. HI
MY NAME'S GILLIAN FROM THE SAN
JOSE CALIFORNIA THANK YOU FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY ONLINE FOR
MORE THAN ONE HALF HOURS- ON
BEHALF OF MY FAMILY AND MY TWO
KIDS I STRONGLY OPPOSE EIGHTY
EIGHT FIVE BY THE WAY LET'S NOT
FORGET ABOUT THE MANY PEOPLE
WHO COULDN'T AS BECAUSE OF
TECHNICAL DIFFICULTIES THEY
WERE ON THE LINE TO. OPPOSE THE
BILL LET'S NOT FORGET THANK YOU
SIR APPRECIATE YOUR PATIENCE
TODAY THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY. NEXT DEADLINE SEVEN
SIXTY EIGHT. HELLO YES GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME ROOM ONE I AM THE-
OUR TIME AND PART TIME WORKING
MOM WE'RE- KIDS LARA COLOR AND
FOR WE ARE ONLY OPEN THE FIRE.
MAXWELL THAT ALIGN SEVEN NINETY
FOUR. I DO YOU MIGHT. FROM
DEREK BELL THAT I'M QUITE OFTEN
AND RIVER NO LIMIT LOCAL. I.
SHANI APPROACH EIGHTY EIGHT
FIVE. THANK YOU. NEXT LINE
SEVEN OH EIGHT. SEVEN HUNDRED
HELLO GO AHEAD HI MY NAME IS. I
THANK THOUSANDS OF HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENT PARENT GROCERY. ON
BALANCE AND PLEASE DON'T STRONG
STRONG BOTH A THREE EIGHT FIVE
ANY JUDGMENT THEY FOUND REYES
COLOR IS APPARENTLY FOR THE
NATION THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY. NEXT LINE SIX
TWENTY TWO. SIX TWENTY TWO. YOU
HAVE A TIME UNITS AT SIX TWENTY
TWO. WELCOME TO THE NEXT ONE
THAT IS NINE SEVEN SIXTY. SEVEN
SIX ZERO. HI MY NAME IS YOUNG
CHANEL. I AM FROM IRVINE IN
ORANGE COUNTY. AND I'M STRONGLY
OPPOSED TO IT SHOULD BE FINE.
YOU. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY CHECK ALL THAT I'LL-
HI NEXT DEADLINE. EIGHT
THIRTEEN EIGHT ONE THREE. HEAD
EIGHT THIRTEEN. ONE MINUTE TO
THE NEXT ONE MIND FIVE SEVENTY
THREE. HI MY NAME'S LAURA. AND
WE CALIFORNIA CONTRA COSTA
VOLATILE COMBINATION THAT
REPRESENT FIVE NUMBER I'M WELL.
FOR ONE OH EIGHT EIGHT FIVE.
PROVISIONS OR NINE KIND HAD
BECOME THANK YOU FOR TESTIMONY
MA'AM WATCH GET STATE IN OUR
OPPOSITION AND THEN THE
FILIATION. THANK YOU YOU. NEXT
DEADLINE FIVE SIXTY TWO. FIVE
HELLO HELLO HELLO. HI MY NAME
IS ALEX NILES I AM A STUDENT AT
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA SANTA
BARBARA I'M ALSO A RESIDENT OF
SANTA CRUZ COUNTY CALIFORNIA
AND I WOULD LIKE TO STRONGLY
STRONGLY VERY STRONGLY EXPRESS
MY SUPPORT. FOUR EIGHTY EIGHT
FIVE FOUR THANK YOU SIR WILL
TAKE IN OPPOSITION WRITING THAT
APPRECIATE YOUR CALL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WE HEAR YOU. ACCESS
NINE SIX FORTY THREE. SIX FORTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. CHECK
YOUR MUTE. WILL MOVE I AM NOT
GOING TO BE A LINE SEVEN EIGHTY
THREE. NINE SEVEN EIGHTY THREE.
MOVE TO THE NEXT ONE. FIND FOUR
EIGHTY ONE. THREE THREE NINE
RECORD FOR EIGHTEEN I. I'M NOT
TO THE NEXT I AM NOT. FIVE
NINETY. I'VE NINE ZERO. HELLO
IT. YES HI GOOD MORNING. THAT A
LOS ANGELES. ADVANCE HATER AND
I STRONGLY. EIGHTY EIGHT. THANK
YOU THANK YOU. ACCESS LINE.
EIGHT NINETEEN EIGHT ONE NINE.
HELLO GOOD MORNING. ISRAEL
CALLING FROM SAN JOSE REPRESENT
IN MY FAMILY WHICH TO KEEPING
HIGH SCHOOL. I STRONGLY OPPOSE
PAGE EIGHTY FIVE PLEASE VOTE.
THANK YOU. NEXT DEADLINE EIGHT
THIRTY EIGHT. YES I HAD. WELL
THE WHOLE THING AND THE CLEAN.
FROM AGES NINE OUR BROOKLYN.
BOB. AND WE'RE GONNA GO TO NEXT
SOMEONE ABLE TO HEAR YOU. NEXT
DEADLINE EIGHT THIRTY FOUR. FOR
ME. YES. WHAT I'M ALTHOUGH. I
WITH YOU I WOULD ALL UP FOR YOU
ALL- THE EIGHTY FIVE WELL.
MAXWELL THAT ALIGN SEVEN NINETY
ONE. SEVEN NINE ONE I IS NOT ME
YES THAT. GIVE ME ONE.
REPRESENTING THE PUBLIC OUT
WORKING CHILDREN OPPOSING FIVE
WELL A JUDGE PEOPLE ON THEIR
SKIN COLOR. THANK YOU. NEXT
DEADLINE EIGHT FORTY ONE.WELL
LET ME YESTERDAY. STATE MY NAME
IS TONY ONE FROM ABOUT A BILL
AND I REPRESENT OVER FOUR
THOUSAND PARENTS THE OWNER-
THAT MYSTERY. WHICH IS ONLY
OPPOSED TO RETHINK THEIR EIGHT
THE BILL AND YOU GUYS.
EDUCATION AND THE YOU PUT THE
DEADLINE. DO YOU BELIEVE NO
MATTER EVEN BEFORE YOU READ
THAT RIGHT NOW THAT THE LAW THE
PRECURSOR THANK YOU SIR WE
APPRECIATE YOUR ONLY ONLY.
THANK PLEASE MOVE MODERATE. MAC
TOOK OUT ALL NINE SEVEN SIXTY
TWO. HELLO THAT YES GO AHEAD.
ALL MY NAME IS. I BOB FROM
SOMEBODY CALL I AND THAT MY
FAMILY TOTALLY FREE PEOPLE.
RESPOND HERE TO IT EIGHTY EIGHT
FIVE. THANK YOU. NEXT DEADLINE
EIGHT TWENTY SEVEN HI MY- JEFF
THAT THE BUT YOU KNOW. I'M
STRUCK THEIR POSE FIVE THIRTY
WOULD WAIT DISTRICTS IS BY
EDUCATE THAT HUMAN BUT- READ
ABOUT. THANK YOU FOR YOUR THANK
REACHED THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ACTIVE MIND ONE FIFTY THAT'S
ONE FIVE ZERO. EIGHT A HIGH- I
AND I'M CALLING TO EXPRESS MY
OPPOSITION AGAIN IS A FIVE-
THIS- THIS FIFTY FIVE IS GONNA
CREATE- CONFLICT BETWEEN RACES
THANK YOU SIR APPRECIATE YOUR
TESTIMONY IN OPPOSITION WE HEAR
YOU PLEASE MOVE ON MODERATOR.
ACCESS LINE SIX NINETY SEVEN.
HI IN MY NAME IS A YOUNG BAND
ON BOARD MEMBER OFF AND GIGGLE
ASIAN AMERICAN FULL EQUALITY ON
BEHALF OF ALL OF ONE THOUSAND
NUMBER AND MY FAMILY WITH THREE
KIDS WE STRONGLY STRONGLY
OPPOSE EIGHTY EIGHT FIVE WE DO
NOT WHILE MORE RACIAL
POPULATION. HELLO ANGEL
DISCRIMINATION THANK YOU KNOW.
THANK YOU. NEXT CALL THAT ALIGN
TO SEVENTEEN THAT TWO ONE SEVEN.
HELLO MY NAME IS STRONG FROM
SAN DIEGO I STRONGLY OPPOSE
EIGHT K. FIVE. NOBODY SHOULD BE
JUDGED BY THEIR CULTURAL SCREEN
PLEASE VOTE NO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR TESTIMONY. THAT
ACT. TWENTY EIGHT. SIX TWENTY
EIGHT GO HAND IN. YEAH. THE
NINE I WILL GO TO NEXT LINE.
EIGHT THIRTY FIVE. MY NAME IS
MICHAEL FROM AN EAGLE AND I'M A
PEOPLE OF COLOR. REPRESENTING
YOU CAN OPEN IT IS FOR ALL
ARGUE WORKERS. WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE A THREE FIVE BECAUSE IT
IS THE TIME TO RESTORE.
ATTENDING A SUPPORT MISSION
THANK YOU SIR APPRECIATE YOUR
TESTIMONY TODAY IN OPPOSITION
WE HEAR YOU PLEASE MOVE ON
MODERATOR. NEXT DEADLINE NINETY
FOUR. MY NINETY FOR YOU I MEAN.
MY NINETY FOUR. HELLO BY HAND.
IT ON ME YES THAT IS. HI MY
NAME IS JENNY AND I'M
CALIFORNIA RESIDENT TO
REPRESENT MY FAMILY I'M
STRONGLY OF THE CA FINE IT IS
RACIAL DISCRIMINATION DEAL AND
FINALLY THE US CONSTITUTION
AMENDMENT FOURTEEN AND IT
DIVIDE ABOUT CALIFORNIA INTO
THE GLOBAL USING THEM A FEW
FEATURE TESTAMENT TODAY. THANK
YOU WE- NEXT DEADLINE. SEVEN
TWENTY THREE. NINE SEVEN TWENTY
THREE. MUTE YES GO AHEAD. THE
MORNING SENATORS MY NAME HOME
SHOE- REPRESENTING TEN THOUSAND
PEOPLE IN THE AREA YEAH OKAY TO
BACK RIGHT CAN YOU COMMITTEE
WITH STRONGLY OPPOSED TO EIGHTY
EIGHT FIVE EIGHT OH NO THANK
YOU. THANK YOU THANK LINE SEVEN
FORTY THAT SEVEN FOUR ZERO.
EIGHT AREN'T. FROM BANI WELL
AND MY MOM UP TO DATE I JOHNNY
AND HELD A BEARD FIVE PLEASE
VOTE NO ON THAT THANK YOU SO
MUCH THANK YOU. NEXT DEALINE.
EIGHT HUNDRED. HI SO HERE I AM
I WILL BE SPENT. IT CATERS. I
THANK. THANK YOU THIS
CALIFORNIA. AND THEY- WARD
ACA'S FIVE THANK YOU THANK YOU
YOU. NEXT DEADLINE SIX THIRTY
FOUR. SIX THIRTY FOUR ARE YOU
ON MUTE. HI ALL THAT AT THE
NECKLINE SIX TWENTY ONE. HELLO
HELLO. HELLO MY NAME IS JIMMY I
WOULD PRESENT MY FAMILY- I
STRONGLY OPPOSED TO EIGHTY FIVE
DEAL PLEASE VOTE ON ABC A FIVE
THANK YOU THANK YOU. NEXT. TO
LINE BY MORNING HI GOOD MORNING
THIS IS JENNIFER HERE I'M FROM
ELK GROVE I'M REPRESENTING MY
FAMILY AND ALL QUITE TO FUNDS
WILL COULD NOT CHOOSE THAT
COLOR BUT THEY WILL FIND IT IS
GREAT COUNTRY SO I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THE BILL EIGHT EIGHT
EIGHT FIVE PLEASE TELL THANK
YOU TO PAY. MATT. NINE FOUR
FOUR THREE. FOUR FORTY THREE.
ARE YOU I MEAN. AND WE'RE GONNA
GO TO THE NEXT LINE NOT BLIND.
TO SEVENTY SEVEN ZERO. SEVENTY.
WILL MOVE TO THE NEXT LINE OF
THAT EIGHT ZERO FOUR EIGHT
HUNDRED AND FOUR. HELLO THEN
YOU EFFORT AT LOW OKAY GOOD
MORNING THE SENATE MY NAME IS
LESLIE I AM WRAPPING I AM
REPRESENTING ASIAN FACTOR THEY
COMMUNICATE FROM BILL BECAUSE
THEY HAD WELL YEAH WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE EIGHTY FIVE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY.
MAX WE WILL THAT ONLINE SIX
SIXTY THREE. SIX SIXTY THREE.
ARE YOU I'M UNIT SIX SIXTY
THREE. A GUY THE NEXT LINE. SIX
FORTY SIX FOUR ZERO. WELL YES
GO AHEAD. WELL YES. HI MY NAME
IS HE LOVES YOU I WOULD PRETEND
THAT CAN BE DONE ALL THE NINE
VILLAGES WE HAVE MORE THAN
THREE THOUSAND MEMBERS AND WE
ARE CLOSING IN THE LIFE AND
DEATH THE OCEAN AT DUKE
COMMITTEE Q. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. ACCESS LINE ONE TWENTY
NINTH ONE TWO ZERO. YES IT IS.
HELLO MY NAME IS TINA. FROM THE
LAST THIRTY YEARS MY FAMILY AND
OF MY COMPANY ALL. GONNA BE OF
BOTH THE EIGHT EIGHT BY. THANK
YOU THANK YOU. NEXT HEADLINE
EIGHT SIXTY SEVEN. GOOD
MORNING. YEAH I'M GONNA HELP
WITH A SMALL DINNER MY HOPE
THAT. THANK THANK YOU. NEXT
DEADLINE THREE. LINE FIFTY
THREE. I AM FIFTY THREE THANK
GOD I HAD. HOW MUCH OF THE NEXT
LINE SEVEN OH ONE. NINE SEVEN
OH ONE ARE YOU AYE MUTE.
AMERICA THE NEXT LINE LINE ONE
NINETY TWO. YES OKAY YEAH MY
MAN IS IT COOL FRONT SAN JOSE-
SANTA CLARA COUNTY I STRONGLY
OPPOSE A FAIR FIGHT THANK YOU.
NEXT LINE SEVEN SEVENTY SEVEN.
HELLO THIS A YEAR FROM SAN
DIEGO I STRONGLY OPPOSE AC
EIGHT. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NEXT DEADLINE FIVE FORTY SIX.
HI MY NAME. FROM FACULTY GRAY I
REPRESENT ONE THOUSAND OF
FAMILIES IN FREMONT GO.
STRONGLY OPPOSE TO INCREASE
FIGHT. THANK YOU. NEXT DEADLINE
EIGHT TWENTY FIVE. GOOD MORNING
MY NAME IS LINDA HOPE FOR OUR
NOT SCHOOL DISTRICT THEN HE
FELT ABOUT HOW MUCH YOU KNOW
SCHOOL DISTRICT WAS STRONGLY
OPPOSED AC A FIVE. NOW THANK
YOU. THANK YOU X. Y. AND ONE
NINETY ONE. NINE ONE NINETY
ONE. YOU HAVE A CEMENT. HELLO
TO THE NEXT LINE EIGHT FIFTY
SEVEN. HI MY NAME IS UP ALL CRY
SHOCK ALREADY BOUGHT TO
CALIFORNIA I'M SPEAKING ON
BEHALF. ALL THE WORKING LOCAL
ASIAN PARENTS THIS STRONGLY OF
COLD. BY BECAUSE THE LEGAL.
DISCRIMINATION BOLTON ALL ON
THIS BE. THANK YOU. NEXT
DEADLINE. FIFTY NINE. I HAD
NAME. FROM I'M SORRY BUT. EIGHT
EIGHT FIVE. NO I DON'T FEEL
THANK YOU THANK YOU. NEXT
DEADLINE. TWO SEVEN. FOR TWENTY
SEVEN YEAH HI THIS IS ONE
PROBLEM. I WOULD THEN. SO YOU
KNOW WHAT IT. EIGHT FIVE JOHN
SO. THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT
DEADLINE ONE TWENTY SEVEN. NINE
ONE TWENTY SEVEN ARE YOU I MEAN.
I AM PROUD OF THE WHOLE THING
MY NAME IS DURING THE YEAR AND
I THE PRESENTING ALMOND AND OUR
CHINESE COMMUNITY WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE AZ YOU FINE THANK YOU
THANK YOU. NEXT DEADLINE FOR
TWENTY SIX. GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS DORIS SIGN LA I AM
STRONGLY OPPOSING EIGHTY FIVE
THANK YOU. NEXT DEADLINE EIGHT
NINETY NINE. AT EIGHT NINETY
NINE. ARE YOU I MEAN. WILL MOVE
TO THE NEXT. ONE NINE FIVE
NINETY THREE. NINE FIVE NINETY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. I YEAH
I'M FINANCE AGAIN CALIFORNIA
OKAY AND A THREE HUNDRED ALONG
NINE MONTH NINE AND IF NOT YOU
COULD YOU RESIDENTS ENOUGH FOR
A NOT CALIFORNIA I. HELLO BY IT
AT THE- TO HER LOOKING PEOPLE
IN PRACTICE THAT BACK RIGHT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. MAXIMUM IN
FACT NINETY EIGHT. HI MY NAME.
DAHLE I'M NOT WORKING MOM AND
THE REPRESENT GOAL OF ONE
THOUSAND. OUR DISTRICT WE ARE
JOHNNY IS JOHNNY JOHNNY APPLE
EIGHT FIVE. VOTE NOW THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ACCESS LINE. EIGHT
SIXTY THREE. I MIGHT SAY THAT
CALLING FROM THE CAR OUT OKAY
WELL I'M NOT IN MY- I REPRESENT
THANK YOU FOR APPLICATION WE
STRONGLY EIGHTY FIVE RESPOND
NOW THANK YOU. THANK YOU AT
LINE. SEVENTY SEVEN NINE
SEVENTY SEVEN. IT IS THE LINK A
LINK WILL BE. EIGHTY EIGHTY
FIVE MEANS WELL BUT EVERY TWO
BELIEVE THAT LEGALIZING GREETED
THEM IT'S THE ONLY WAY TO FIGHT
BREAKING THEM. BUCKLEY ADDED
COMMUNITY TO VOTE NO THANK YOU.
ACCESS LINE PERFECT TAN. HELLO
JOSH- FROM SAN DIEGO I STRONGLY
OPPOSE- AC EIGHT FIVE AND I
QUOTE FROM MIND INTO YOUR TEAM
JUNIA I LOOK TO A DAY ONE
PEOPLE WILL NOT BE JUDGED BY
THE COLOR OF THEIR SKIN BUT BY
THE END OF THEIR I'M QUITE
THANK FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
POSITION WE HEAR YOU THANK YOU.
NEXT DEADLINE EIGHT NINE THAT
EIGHT NINE ZERO. YOU CAN WHICH
I'M BOND OKAY I'M CALLING TO A
FIVE. THANK YOU THANK YOU. NEXT
DEADLINE. EIGHT SEVENTY TWO. I
AND EIGHT SEVENTY TWO. ARE YOU
I MEAN IT. HELLO HI IT IS
LOCATED ON FROM FREMONT
CALIFORNIA I STRONGLY OPPOSE
EIGHT A FIVE BECAUSE I HAVE THE
SAME GRAND THAT LED TO A GOING
AWAY AND ONE DAY LEVY AND
COUNTRY THAT HE'S NOT BY THAT
THAT PAIN. THANK YOU. NEXT
DEADLINE NINE SEVENTEEN. NINE
ONE SEVEN. YOU HAVE A TIME YET
NINE SEVENTEEN. I MOVED TO THE
NEXT. ONE NINE TO FORTY FOUR.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME'S LETICIA.
I AM AN ASIAN AMERICAN WORKING
MOM FROM MOUNTAIN VIEW
CALIFORNIA. I STRONGLY OPPOSE
IF YOU SEE A FIVE. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. LACK OF MINE. NINE
NINETEEN NINE ONE NINE. HELLO
I'M NOT. I CALLED YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT DEADLINE.
NINE THIRTEEN NINE ONE THREE.
YES HELLO THIS IS THE ODD LAN
I'M CALLING FROM EIGHT I LOOK
FOR THEM KATE- PARENT
ASSOCIATION IN ONE HOUR BODY
GET ABOUT AND PARENTS WE FIVE
GIANT HOLD EIGHT EIGHT FIVE
FEET ABOUT NOW THANK YOU THANK
YOU. NEXT LINE. FIVE FIFTEEN
FIVE FIVE ZERO. AND YOUR
LEARNING COULD AT IT'S ME. I
HAD. MONNING MEMBERS IS BETWEEN
ME THEIR DIRECT OF THE FIRST
DEBATE OCT THIRTY MINUTE AND
THAT TRIGGER OF B. U. S. H. ARE
AID COLLEGE STATION. THE
THOUSAND WE ONLY THE ONLY A THE
EIGHT EIGHT FIVE. THANK WELL
THANK YOU. MAX DEADLINE NINE
ALLOW. HELLO YEAH GO AHEAD I
NEED. SENATOR MY NEED NOT SHALL.
ARE ARMORY THE GRANTING ALREADY.
CALLER WOMEN SIGN HAVE NO
ASSOCIATE THE OVER A HUNDRED WE
MEMBERS LED MANY IN FACT FIELD.
OUR STRONGLY BOTH EIGHT FIVE.
WELL RESTORE AT IF THE LATTER
VISUAL MY NAME. I FOUND THE
STATE EIGHT HOW RETURN THE YOU
MA'AM OF JUST ALREADY THANK YOU
DOCTOR. PROCEDURE TO THANK YOU
FOR CALLING THE MOVE ON
UNDERWRITER. NEXT FIVE FORTY.
ONE MY NAME IS JAMES BOND I'M
FROM VENDORS CALIFORNIA I
STRONGLY STRONGLY OPPOSE EIGHTY
EIGHT FIVE BASEBALL NO SPENT
THANK YOU. NEXT DEADLINE FIVE
FORTY ONE. NINE YES. GLORIA
FROM LAWCENTER LANE. I ONLY
ABOUT HOW THE ACA FIVE. MADE
FROM OLD MOUNT ST KILL THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT NEXT WE WILL GO
TO LINE TWO FORTY NINE. HI GOOD
MORNING SENATORS- THIS AWAY
LEAVE FROM SAN DIEGO. I
STRONGLY OPPOSE- EIGHT EIGHT
FIVE EIGHT. EIGHT WOULD YOU TO
DO DISCRIMINATION- WELL NOW
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY TODAY. NEXT
DEADLINE NINE ONE. BY THE LATE.
YES HI MY NAME IS GEORGE LEVY
I'M- WAYS THE ORANGE CLUB OUT
YOU'LL SEE REPRESENTING OVER
HALF MILLION CHINESE AMERICANS
IS ON THE CALIFORNIA AND
OUTLOOK AT OR EQUAL. HE THE
FIVE EYES DOT. IT'S GOING TO.
AND GAVE UP LIKE CHECK TO
GOVERNMENT TO IMPOSE. RACIAL
ASPECTS KALRA EIGHT LITTLE NO
HONEST WHICH IS FAIR THANK
THANK YOU. NECK LINE FOURTEEN.
BUT NINE TO FORTY WAS LAST. IT
WILL MOVE TO THE NEXT. ALLEN
LINE SOKOLOW HELLO YES GO AHEAD
OKAY- MY NAME IS THE AVERAGE
TWELVE BROWN'S BAND PULLED UP
IN FRONT DIFFICULT BAY AREA I'M
ASIAN AMERICAN AND THE ELECTED
THE SCHOOL BOARD MEMBER I'M
STRONGLY OPPOSED EIGHT EIGHT
EIGHT FIVE. THE YOU. NEXT
DEADLINE SEVEN FIFTY TWO. SEVEN
FIFTY TWO. ARE YOU I MEAN OUT.
THE MOVE TO THE NEXT LINE LINE
NINE THIRTY ONE. THIRTY ONE ME
YEAH YES YOU GOOD MORNING MY
NAME ME IN SCHOOL. IN DIEGO
YOUR LIFE CAN BE TRICKY. I
STRONGLY STRONGLY OPPOSED AGE
TO BE EIGHTY FIVE BECAUSE THE
EIGHTY THREE TEN SB WILL RIDE
IT BACK FOR CALIFORNIA. THANK
YOU. MAX LINE. NINE OH EIGHT. I
HAD NINE OH EIGHT. LORRAINE
ADVOCATED CHEN FROM FREMONT I
STRONGLY OPPOSED THE AVIA FIVE
BE OKAY- SB IF I CREATE A
RACIAL DISCRIMINATION AGAINST
PART OF. IF YOU CARRY ON FOR
THE- I'LL HAVE OUR UP MADE
RETURN. FIGHT IS. MAX THAT
ALLOW NINE ONE. NINE FORTY ONE.
GOOD MORNING SENATORS THIS IS
KERRY FROM CONTRA COSTA COUNTY
I'M A MOM OF TWO CHILDREN I'M
STRONG STRONGLY OPPOSED EIGHTY
EIGHT FIVE I HOPE FIVE TO TEN
YEARS LATER. I DON'T NEED TO
ENTER QUESTION FROM MY- MOM WHY
I'M JUDGE BY MY COLOR OF SKI
THANK YOU MA'AM APPRECIATE YOUR
TO LEARNING THANK YOU. MAX SAID
LINE SIX SIXTY ONE. HELLO BY
HAND. I SENT MY NAME'S GRACE
FROM OF COLLEGE. HOW CAN I LEFT
THANK YOU CENTRAL KIND CHINESE
CULTURE. WITH THE MOTHER AND
TEN THOUSAND OF MEMBERS SO WE
STRONGLY OPPOSED EIGHTY FIVE WE
BELIEVE YOU COOK TWENTY SHOULD
BE GIVEN TO ALL RACES. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT HEADLINE
FIVE SEVENTY EIGHT. HELLO. HIGH
UP BY- I YOU BOB YEAH I BUT YOU
ARE. I YEAH IF ANYTHING- EIGHT
EIGHT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NEXT HEADLINE FORTY NINE ZERO.
HELLO MY ANY CHANCE I AM RATED
NINETEEN A LARGE ASIAN
COMMUNITY GROUP HELLO HI ASIAN
AND YOUR FEDERATION I'M
STRONGER. EIGHT FIVE. THE VOTE
BECAUSE THE AC FIVE AGAINST YOU
OPPORTUNITY I'LL BUT DID AMONG
THE DIFFERENT GREAT. THANK YOU
HAVE TIME FOR ONE MORE MAC.
OKAY WELL THAT A LINE NINE
THIRTY FIVE. OKAY THE D. SHE
CALLING FROM SEVEN TELL- OF THE
FINE IS THAT PEOPLE COLOR I
JUST. EIGHTY FIVE THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
FORTUNATELY WE ARE NOW OUT OF
TIME IN THE- TELECONFERENCE
FOR. POSITION AND- WE WILL NOW
BRING IT BACK TO THE- TO THE
COMMITTEE BUT FIRST OF ALL I
WANT TO THANK EVERYONE WHO WAS
ON THE LINE- AND THOSE WHO
HAVE- HAD THE PATIENCE TODAY TO
JUST STAY ON THE LINE AND THANK
YOU FOR THAT- TESTIMONY. BEFORE
AND POSITION. I HAVEN'T. WOULD
LIKE TO CONTINUE VIEW PLEASE TO
OUR COMMITTEE ARE YOU CALL OUR
COMMITTEE AND LEAVE YOUR
TESTIMONY FOR THAT AND- THANK
YOU MODERATOR FOR YOUR GOOD
WORK TODAY AS WELL WE
APPRECIATE IT VERY MUCH IN.
BACK TO THE TO A ANY MEMBERSHIP
ANY OR COMMENTS. FISH SENATOR
CENTER PAN. THANK YOU I MISS
CHAIR AND- YEAH APPRECIATE THE-
VARIOUS COMMENTS AND- TO JUST
PATIENTS PEOPLE ON THIS. IS THE
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENT WHICH
WILL GO TO THE VOTERS SO. WHAT
WE ARE DOING TODAY IS-
BASICALLY DECIDING WHETHER TO
PUT BEFORE THE VOTERS. AND
ALLOW THE VOTERS AND THE PEOPLE
OF CALIFORNIA TO MAKE THIS
DECISION. HOWEVER I DO WANT TO
SPEAK ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF-
RAISING THIS VERY IMPORTANT
ISSUE TO THE VOTERS. AND AT YOU
KNOW FIRST OF ALL I JUST WANNA
SAY AS A MEMBER OF THE ASIAN
PACIFIC ISLANDER TO BE THAT
ACTUALLY ABOUT POLLING HAS
SHOWN THAT THE MAJORITY OF ATI.
SUPPORT ACA FIVE AND PLACE IT
BEFORE THE VOTERS. SO I JUST
WANNA MAKE THAT VERY CLEAR-
SECOND OF ALL- I DO HEAR AND
RECOGNIZE THAT THERE IS A
SEGMENT OF THE API COMMUNITY.
EARLIER CHINESE AMERICANS WHO
HAVE CONCERNS. ABOUT THIS AND I
THINK IT IT- YOU KNOW I WILL
TELL YOU I'M A FATHER I HAVE.
CHILDREN I REMEMBER FLYING
COLLAGEN HEARING RUMORS ABOUT
QUOTAS AND- CERTAINLY-
DISCRIMINATION AGAINST
APPLICANTS TO OUR- CHINESE
AMERICAN. ASIAN SOME OF THAT
PERHAPS GROUNDED IN. HERE THEIR
MEDIUM DUTY BEEN SOME TRUTH TO
THAT. BUT IT WASN'T BECAUSE
BLACK OR BROWN APPLICANTS WE'RE
GOING TO TAKE AWAY MY SPOT THE
FACT I WOULD SAY THAT
REALISTICALLY IS GOING TO BE
THE ALUM FRIENDS OR THE WHO HAD
THE WHERE WITH ALL TO
PARTICIPATE IN CERTAIN SUPPORT.
THAT APPS WITH. RELIEVED CAN
AGAINST NOT BASED ON OUR MERITS
BUT BASED ON THEIR PRIVILEGE
AND WELL. AND SO CERTAINLY I
HERE'S THE FEAR THAT. SOME OF
THE- AT WHO ARE AND OPPOSITION-
THEY'RE CONCERNED ABOUT THEIR
OWN CHILDREN'S CHANCES OF
GETTING A SO CALLED TOP SLOTS
ARE TOP COLLEGE AND BUT I THINK
WE NEED TO REALLY EXAMINE WHAT
THE ISSUE IS WHEN IT COMES. THE
THING THAT I ALSO WANT TO
MENTION IS. I'M CERTAINLY I
THINK MANY OF US WANT TO
EMBRACE THIS IDEA OF A
MERITOCRACY. BUT HOW DO YOU
HAVE A MERITOCRACY WHEN WE HAVE
STRUCTURAL RACISM. AND I WANT
TO SPEAK SPECIFICALLY TO THE
API COMMUNITY. BECAUSE OF ALL I
THINK MANY OF US- EXPERIENCE NO
MATTER HOW MANY GENERATIONS OUR
FAMILY HAVE BEEN IN THE UNITED
STATES WITH THE REFORM HERE
OVER IMMIGRANTS YEAR. OF IN
NINETEEN. AT THE COLOR OF OUR
SKIN OR PERHAPS THE SLANT OF
ARISE OR WHATEVER OTHER FEATURE.
LOOK MORE DEEPLY. AND THEY
BLAMED US AND WE WERE CALLED
FOREIGNERS AND PEOPLE WHO
SPREAD DISEASES WHEN. WAS ARE
THE ONES WHO ARE TAKING
ACTUALLY MANY. TO HELP SPREAD
THE DISEASE. AND I HOPE THAT'S
A REMINDER THAT UNFORTUNATELY
AS MUCH AS WE MAY DESIRE. THE
SITUATION THERE IS WORK TO BE
DONE. THE SECOND THING I'D ALSO
WANT TO MENTION IS ACTUALLY I
CHAIR THE- SELECT COMMITTEE ON
EIGHTY I'VE ERRORS. AND WHEN WE
HAD A HEARING LOOKING AT
ESSENTIALLY THE GLASS CEILING
FOR API. SO LET ME JUST GIVE
ONE EXAMPLE I APPRECIATE YOUR
INDULGENCE ON THE SHARE. I'M A
PHYSICIAN ALL RIGHT AND
CERTAINLY. BUT PLAN A POLITE TO
MEDICAL SCHOOL WE CAN LOOK
AROUND AND SOME ASIANS I WANNA
SAY ONLY SOME PACIFIC ISLANDERS
DO NOT- MAY BE OF THE SOUTHEAST
ASIANS ARE UNDER REPRESENTS
DIDN'T IN MEDICINE. MY IS SO IS
A LOT OF IMMIGRANTS FROM. WE
ARE YOU KNOW OVER READ. IN THIS
PART PORTION THE ELATION. OUR.
WELL DOING PRETTY WELL THEY'RE
GREAT. WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
PARCHMENT TEARS. NOT SO WELL
WHEN YOU LOOK AT DEAN'S TO
THINK ABOUT IT. WE HAVE LIKE A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY SOME MEDICAL
SCHOOLS IN THE UNITED STATES WE
DON'T HAVE A SINGLE API MEDICAL
SCHOOL DEAN. SO WHAT HAPPENED.
LOOK AT THE DEPARTMENT CHAIRS
WHAT HAPPENED THERE AND SO I
GUESS I WOULD RAISE THE ISSUE
OF. IS IT BECAUSE- YOUR WE ALSO
UNQUALIFIED FOR PROMOTION TO
SERVE IN SENIOR MANAGEMENT
POSITIONS TO SERVE AS
EXECUTIVES TO SERVE ON
CORPORATE BOARDS THIS IS ALL
NOT ONLY ABOUT MEDICINE THIS IS
ACROSS MANY DIFFERENT
PROFESSIONS. WERE NOT WILLING
TO HAVE A CONVERSATION ABOUT
HOW REYES PLAYS INTO. BUT AS
EMISSIONS TO SCHOOLS ARE HIGHER
EDUCATION TO OUR CONTRACTS THAT
WITH THE GOVERNMENT. TO HIRING.
HOW CAN WE HELP TO HAVE THAT
CONVERSATION ABOUT HOW REYES
PLAYS INTO THE FACT THAT. MANY
API ALSO ARE NOT GETTING OUR
FAIR CHANCE. TO SERVE IN
LEADERSHIP POSITIONS AS WELL
WHETHER IT'S IN THE PRIVATE
SECTOR IN OUR PROFESSIONS IN
OTHER ARENAS YEAH SO I THINK WE
REALLY WANT TO BE HONEST ABOUT
THIS CONVERSATION. CAN I AND-
RACE DOESN'T MATTER AND THAT
PEOPLE WILL NOT LOOK AT IS THIS
WAY AND SO I THINK I HOPE THAT
I CERTAINLY HERE THE OPPOSITION.
I CERTAINLY SYMPATHIZE THEIR
FEARS. BUT I ALSO THINK THAT
THE PROGRAM AN HONEST
CONVERSATION ABOUT HOW REYES
PLAYS INTO THE OPPORTUNITIES
FOR PROVIDE PEOPLE IN OUR
SOCIETY I'M WE NEED TO PASS A
CA FIRES SO CERTAINLY I ALWAYS
THE VOTING IN SUPPORT AND- THE
VOTE. CAN HAVE THEIR OP TO
WEIGH IN ON THIS BUT I ALSO ASK
THAT. THOSE WHO ARE IN
OPPOSITION TO REALLY THINK
ABOUT. WHAT WE NEED TO DO TO
ADDRESS. CERTAINLY NOT TO USE
FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS EVEN FOR
OWN COMMUNITY AND HOW IMPORTANT
THE CONVERSATION AROUND A SEAT
A FIVE WILL BE FOR EVEN. THEIR
OWN FAMILY AND THEIR OWN
CHILDREN AND THE THAT IS
THEY'LL HAVE AND CERTAINLY
AGAIN IS WHAT REEMPHASIZED THE
API COMMUNITY AT LARGE DOES
SUPPORT AC FIVE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. IF YOU DOCTOR AND
SENATOR MITCHELL. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER A CHAIR AND AS
PROUD CO AUTHOR OF THE BILL I
WOULD LIKE MOVE THE BILL. AND
I'D LIKE TO SAY THAT I LISTENED
TO- THE DEBATE TODAY AND ONE
MEMBER THE PUBLIC CHALLENGED US
TO LISTEN TO OUR CONSTITUENTS.
AND I AM. ALL MY OFFICE HAS
RECEIVED TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND
EMAILS TO MY PUBLIC ACCOUNTS.
95% OF WHICH WERE NEITHER MY
CONSTITUENTS AND A GOOD NUMBER
OF THEM WEREN'T EVEN RESIDENTS
OF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. SO
I AM LISTENING TO MY
CONSTITUENTS. AND THOSE ARE
KAISER PERMANENTE A ADVANCEMENT
PROJECT ASIAN AMERICANS
ADVANCING JUSTICE THE ALLIANCE
FOR BOYS AND MEN OF COLOR TO
BLACK STUDENTS OF CALIFORNIA
UNITED THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE THE
COMMISSION ON THE STATUS OF
WOMEN. ARE CONSTITUTIONAL OFF
COMMISSIONPART A LARA AN
CONTROLLER BETTY. I'M LISTENING
TO MY MAYOR AIR GUARD THREE
LAUSD SCHOOL DISTRICT ONCE FEET
ONE. CARE C. THE KOREAN
RESOURCE CENTER LARA. THE
CAMPAIGN FOR COLLEGE
OPPORTUNITY TO THE SIERRA CLUB
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
STUDENT ASSOCIATION THE UFC
RACE IN EQUITY CENTER IN THE
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY I AM LISTENING TO MY
CONSTITUENTS. AND IT STRIKES ME.
ANY ONE WOULD CHOOSE TO OPPOSE
A POLICY THAT AIMS TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE ROLE THAT DOT
PLAYS IN ONE BILL. TO ACCESS
HIGHER EDUCATION IN THEIR
BUSINESS OPPORTUNITIES THAT IN
AND OF ITSELF IS BEYOND ME.
WHAT I DO HERE AND WHAT I FIND
QUITE PAINFUL. IS A BLATANT
DISREGARD FOR THE HISTORY OF
LIFE EXPERIENCE. FOR A GROUP OF
PEOPLE OTHER THAN ONE'S OWN.
THAT FROM MY PERSPECTIVE IN AND
OF ITSELF COULD BE CONSIDERED
BY US. I'D LIKE TO COMPLIMENT
THE COMMITTEE CONSULTANT FOR
WRITING A VERY COMPREHENSIVE
ANALYSIS. I WOULD ENCOURAGE ALL
INCLUDING THE MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC TO READ IT I'M SURE CAN
BE FOUND ON THE SENATE LABOR
COMMITTEES WEBSITE. WHAT'S
IMPORTANT ON PAGE TWO OF THIS
ANALYSIS IS IT. PROP TWO OH
NINE PASSED IN NINETEEN NINETY
SIX IN A HISTORICAL CONTEXT IT
REMINDS US OF WHAT WAS GOING ON
IN OUR STATE DURING THAT TIME.
BEN ALTHEA NOW STATES ONE OF
THE CO AUTHORS OF THE
CALIFORNIA CIVIL RIGHTS
INITIATIVE WHICH BECAME PROP
TWO OH NINE WAS AN
ANTHROPOLOGIST AT THE CAL STATE
SYSTEM GLAND CONSTRUED. WHO N
A BOOK THE FIFTY TWO OH NINE
THE BOOK ENTITLED THE COLOR
BLIND CALIFORNIA'S BATTLE TO
END AFFIRMATIVE ACTION HE
DESCRIBED HIS JOB TO UPHOLD BUT
ACTION. BORN FOR HE DID. HURT
WORTH DIVERSE THE AND MORE
CULTURALISM. AND HE SAID I
QUOTE PERMISSION TO READ MISTER
CHAIRMAN THANK YOU. AS AN
ANTHROPOLOGIST I KNOW WHAT I
KNOW THAT WHEN YOU'VE GOT
DIVERSITY. YOU HAVE A PROBLEM.
WHICH MEANS THAT YOU'VE GOT TO
COME UP WITH WAYS TO DEAL WITH
IT AND THE MOST REALISTIC WAY
POSSIBLE. HE ALSO DESCRIBE
MULTI CULTURALISM IS QUOTE. IF
WITH CONFIRMED FULL AMERICA WAS
NOT POSSIBLE WITHOUT A COMMON
GROUND BETWEEN ALL AMERICANS.
WE'RE AMERICA COULD FIND
QUESTIONS COMMON GROUND IS
UNCLEAR BUT APPARENTLY IT WAS
NOT FOUND IN EITHER MULTI
CULTURALISM OR ARE CITY. RATHER
NOTING THE TECH FOR THE
CALIFORNIA CIVIL RIGHTS
INITIATIVE THE COMMON GROUND IS
IN THE DENIAL OF DIFFERENCES A
COLOR BLIND AND GENDER BLIND
SOCIETY. I WOULD ARGUE THAT
MANY OF THE ARGUMENTS I'VE
RECEIVED IN OPPOSITION TO A CA
FIVE ON OUR. FULL OF MIS
INFORMATION AND TRAGICALLY.
ANTI THE THEIR VITRIOLIC IN
TERMS OF THEIR COMMENTS ABOUT.
PEOPLE OF COLOR QUITE FRANKLY.
IN ON WHATEVER YOUR PERCEPTION
IS OF WHAT A COLOR BLIND
SOCIETY EVEN IS. THE DATA
SUGGESTS THAT WE ARE NOT
CURRENTLY LIVING IN ONE.
INSTEAD THE DATA SUGGEST THAT
WE LIVE IN A DEEPLY ON EQUAL
SOCIETY WITH THE TOOLS TO
COMPLETE COMPETE IN SOCIETY ARE
ON EVENLY DISTRIBUTED AND
DISTRIBUTED IN A MANNER THAT
PROTECTS YOU AIDS WE QUALITY
BETWEEN RACES AND GENDER AT ALL
LEVELS OF CLASS IN SOCIETY. YOU
HEARD A NUMBER OF WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION- ACKNOWLEDGE THEIR
ROLE AS MOTHER. I TO LIMóN MY-
AND THEY TALKED ABOUT NOT
WANTING TO HAVE TO TELL THEIR
CHILDREN THAT THEY WERE BEING
JUDGED BY THE COLOR OF THEIR
SKIN IN TEN YEARS. I HAVE TO
MAKE SURE THAT MY SON
UNDERSTAND THAT HE'S JUDGED BY
THE COLOR OF HIS SKIN EVERY
SINGLE DAY OF HIS. YOU KNOW
PERSONALLY THIS NOTION OF A
COLOR BLIND SOCIETY I FIND
OFFENSIVE. BECAUSE IT DID NOT
ICE WHO I AM MY CALL BY RICH
CULTURAL HERITAGE THE HERITAGE
AND BACKGROUND BUT I'M QUITE
PROUD OF. FOOD COLOR BLIND.
IT'S ABOUT RISK. IN DIFFERENT
FIFTH. THEY ALLEGING THAT ME
AND YOU KNOW WHO ARE AM AS A
WOMAN AMERICA. AND SO FOR ALL
THOSE REASONS AGAIN IT GIVES ME
GREAT PRIDE TO CREATE AN
OPPORTUNITY. IN TWENTY TWENTY.
NOT IN NINETEEN NINETY SIX WERE
WE HAD A AMBITIOUS THE GOVERNOR
WHO WAS TRYING TO RUN FOR
PRESIDENT THAT WAS GOING TO RUN
ON THE BACKS OF FEAR THAT HE
HAD PREPARED THE WAY. OF
IMMIGRANTS AND THESE OF COLOR.
NO NINETY NINE SIX COMING OFF
OF THE PASSAGE OF PROP ONE
EIGHTY SEVEN AGAIN AT
INITIATIVE- THE FRAME DIDN'T
CAST IN THIS NOTION OF FEAR OF
PEOPLE WERE DIFFERENT FROM YOU.
BUT WE'RE GOING TO MAKE SURE
THE ACA FIVE GETS ON THE BALLOT
IN NOVEMBER OF TWENTY TWENTY.
IN THE MIDDLE OF AN
INTERNATIONAL AWAKENING. ABOUT
THE ROLE BIAS IMPLICIT AND
EXPLICIT HAS PLAYED ON OUR
WORLD IN OUR COUNTRY AND OUR
STATE. AND SO AGAIN IT GIVES ME
GREAT PLEASURE TO CO AUTHOR AND
TO MOVE THE BILL AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME MISTER CHAIR I
WILL READ A THREE EIGHT FIVE
TODAY THANK YOU SENATOR
MITCHELL SENATOR. THANK YOU
MISTER POCH CHAIR AND MEMBERS
AND I ALSO APPRECIATED THE
ROBUST DISCUSSION. ARE ALSO THE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE IN SUPPORT AND
THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE IN
OPPOSITION. YOU KNOW A QUARTER
OF A CENTURY OF. PROP TWO OH
NINE WAS ON THE BALLOT. IT WAS
A DIFFERENT CALIFORNIA AND
INDEED A DIFFERENT GENERATION.
MANY OF THE PEOPLE WHO WILL BE
OUR CONSIDERING THIS A POLICY
ARE WEREN'T EVEN BORN. WHEN
THEY PASSED IT EIGHTEEN NINETY
SIX IF WE WERE TO PUT THIS ON
THE BALLOT AND I THINK WHAT WE
HAVE COME TO REALIZE IN
CALIFORNIA IS THAT DIVERSITY IS
OUR STRENGTH. THAT BY BRINGING
TOGETHER. AMERICANS AND PEOPLE
WHO WANT TO BE AMERICANS AND
PEOPLE WHO WANT TO LIVE HERE
AND EXPERIENCE THE GREAT.
PROMISE OF CALIFORNIA IN THE
UNITED STATES THEY HAVE BUILT
THE ECONOMY OF THE STATE. THEY
HAVE BUILT THE RICH CULTURAL
TRADITIONS THE STATE NATION.
AND THE NOTION THAT WE BELIEVE
TO TWENTY FIVE YEARS AGO THAT
BY DENYING OUR DIFFERENCES WE
WOULD BE ELEVATING EVERYBODY.
HAS BEEN PROVEN TO BE
COMPLETELY. THE OPPOSITE.
WHETHER IT'S RACE OR GENDER.
YOU KNOW I HAVE DONE IN THE
COURSE OF MY LEGISLATIVE CAREER
A NUMBER OF BILLS TO GIVE WOMEN
AN OPPORTUNITY TO COMPETE
EQUALLY IN OUR SOCIETY. WE ARE
STILL IN THAT BATTLE. WE STILL
HAVE NOT RECEIVED ACHIEVED THAT
LEVEL OF EQUALITY. BECAUSE WE
ARE A BIASED WORLD WE MAKE
ASSUMPTIONS ABOUT PEOPLE BASED
UPON THEIR RACE THEIR CREED%
THEIR NATIONAL ORIGIN THEIR
GENDER WHICH CASH HISTORICALLY
KEPT THEM DOWN. THIS
OPPORTUNITY IS FOR US TO
REEVALUATE WHO WE ARE AS A
STATE WHAT WE WANT TO BE AS A
STATE AND WHO WE ARE AS A
PEOPLE. AND SO YOU SEE THIS IS.
TO NAY. THIS ICAC FIVE AS IN A
POP. NOT TO PRO AN ADVANTAGE
BUT TO PROVIDE AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR EVERYBODY TO BE ABLE TO
COMPETE EQUALLY AND I THINK IT
IS INCOME ON US THE SONG BALLOT
SO THAT THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE SIDE. THIS
SO. UP REYES ENGENDERED BY
PAULA HAS EFFECTIVE AND WHETHER
IT'S CAN TO BE PURSUED BECAUSE
IF YOU LOOK AT WHAT THIS WORLD
LOOKS LKE TODAY OUR CALIFORNIA
LOOKS LIKE TODAY CLEARLY THIS
ISSUE DESERVES AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR THE PEOPLE TO GET. I TRULY.
NOT THAT ARE DUE. ARE BASED.
AND NOT PUSH UNDER THE RUG. AND
SO WITH THAT I WANT TO JOIN AND
THANK THE AUTHOR AND-
APPRECIATE THE CONCERNS WE
REALLY NEED TO BE MOTIVATED BY
FAT AND NOT FEAR AND THAT IS MY
HOPE IS THIS MEASURE- DOES
HOPEFULLY PROCEED. ON THE
BALLOT THE BILL OF ONE YEAR
HAVE THE- TO MAKE THAT DECISION
THANK YOU THANK YOU JACKSON. OF
SENIOR ELSE IN THE SHE JUST
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BACK TO WORK
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. YES
FIRST OF ALL LET ME THANK ALL
OF YOU FOR PATIENCE MISTY TO
FOR YOU TOM PATIENTS WELL THE
WE SAID THEM SUCH A LONG SAID
OF HEARING AND COMMON THAT
WOULD BE. OWN I THINK ALL OF
WHO DO TESTIFY I THINK IS AND
TO PEOPLE BEEN UP TO SOME. WITH
IT IN A BILL OR POST WHAT LEARN
A LOT WHAT WE HE AND WHAT THE
FEARS ARE WITH THE CA. ARE AS
LEAD TO SINCE WHILE WELCOME
OPPOSITE. SO LET'S BUILT. IN
ETHNIC STUDIES FOR SO LONG- I
WOULD NEVER INTRODUCE ANY BILL
THAT WOULD PROMOTE
DISCRIMINATION AND HER AND HARM
TO ANY PARTICULAR GROUP.
ACTUALLY RESPECT DIVERSITY THAT
IS CALIFORNIA AND IT IS
CALIFORNIA'S STRENGTH. AT AND
YOU HAVE A CALIFORNIA TO
RECOGNIZE THAT IT IS STRONG
BECAUSE OF THE PEOPLE WHO LIVE.
AND WHO COME WHO EXPECT TO BE
EXPECTED. WE ALSO HAVE TO
REALIZE THAT WE CAN NEVER A
PROBLEM THAT WE REFUSE TO SEE.
AND THAT'S WHAT WE SEE IN THE
STREET TODAY A PROBLEM THAT HAS
EXISTED INFESTED SO LONG. AND
WE HAVE TURNED A BLIND EYE TO
IT BELIEVING THAT BECAUSE WE
HAVE A WONDERFUL STATE WITH
WONDERFUL BEACHES AND ONE
OTHER. BUT SOMEHOW THAT WITH
ALL OF THE ILLS OF CALIFORNIA.
DOES NOT AND SO WITH THAT IN
MIND THERE'S A- AND A EVEN
THOUGH MY NAME IS IN THIS. IS
THE FIRST. I WILL LET BECAUSE
WAS THAT'S- TO BE I WAS CLOSE
ME LAST NAME. I DON'T KNOW WHO
TWISTED ALL ROUND BUT ANYWAY.
MY NAME IN THE BE THE FIRST
NAME ON THE BILL THIS BILL IS A
COALITION OF PEOPLE IN THE
HOUSE. OF THIS QUOTATION OF ALL
THE- CARCASSES THE MEN'S
CAUCUS. THE APS CAUGHT THE
JEWISH POCKET. IN A I I'M
TRYING TO BE A BLACK EIGHT L.
G. B. CALL. ALL OF THE END OF
WHO KNOW HOW IMPORTANT IT IS TO
BE INCLUDED. TO BE GIVEN AN
OPPORTUNITY TO BE SUCCESSFUL.
I'M ALWAYS PLEASED WITH SO MANY
PEOPLE QUOTE MARTIN LUTHER KING
NO MATTER WHERE YEARS HIS NAME
IS ALWAYS INVOLVED IN HIS WORDS
ALWAYS IMPORTANT. BUT THEY HAVE
TO REALIZE THE TRUE KING THE
FULL KING THAT IS THAT. WHEN HE
TALKED ABOUT I DON'T WANT TO BE
JUDGED BY THE CONTENT THE COLOR
OF MY SKIN BUT THE CONTENT OF
MY CHARACTER. THAT WAS
CONTAINED IN THE I HAVE A DREAM
SPEECH THAT WAS IT THREE. THAT
WAS NOT READ. THAT WAS DURING
WHAT. THE RACE. WHAT DO YOU WE
WOULD ACHIEVE BUT HE REALLY IN
THE THAT YOU HAVE TO CONTINUE
TO FIGHT. THAT IN THE THAT YOU
HAD TO RECOGNIZE THE- BEFORE
YOU EVER SAW. PEOPLE THEY CAN'T
KEEP IT. WE HAVE YET. I THANK.
AND AS WE GO CLOSER SOME OTHER
WEEK PUSHED BACK FURTHER OF AND
SO WE HAVE TO CONSCIOUS OF THE
FACT THAT THIS IS A- THAT ALL
OF THIS YEAR NONE OF US TO BE
JUDGED. OF OURS. SOMETIMES THE
COLOR OF OUR SKIN TO DEVELOP
OUR CHARACTER. IT HELPS TO MAKE
A STRONG. HELPS US TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT WE CONTRIBUTE
TO THE WORLD. THIS BILL ACA
FIVE. IS A BILL LONGING TO COME
TO THIS HOUSE AND TO THE PEOPLE
OF CALIFORNIA. BECAUSE WE NEED
THIS COMP XIN. WITH THIS
EFFORT. WE NEED TO KNOW. WHAT
IT. DID TAKE AFFIRMATIVE STEPS.
WHICH DOESN'T MEAN GIVING AWAY
THINGS BUT HE SAYS IT TO HAVE
MADE A CONSCIOUS EFFORT. A
CONSCIOUS EFFORT TO BREAK DOWN
THE BARRIERS THAT EXIST IN OUR
SOCIETY. A CONSCIOUS EFFORT TO
GET RID OF SEX. AND REYES SOME.
THE MEETING CONSCIOUS EFFORT.
TO SEE TO SEE THE ABILITY OF IN
THE- IN THE- CALIFORNIA AND-
THEM THE- TO GO INTO THE- OUR-
TO. THANK YOU FOR YOUR- IT'S I
THINK ALL OF US FOR TO A
CALLOUS YOU THAT. EIGHT THE
NOTE IS LONG IS THAT IN ORDER
TO ACHIEVE THE DREAM YOU AFTER
UP AND WHAT YOU ARE AND BEGIN
TO TOWARDS THE JURY SO WITH
THAT IN MY I WAS FOR ALL YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND YOUR TIME
IS A TWO YEAR AND RESPECTFULLY
ASK I BOTH THE ACA FIVE. THANK
YOU MUCH DOCTOR WEBER AND-
FIRST THE- I WANT TO BEGIN BY
THANKING YOU. FOR YOUR
STEADFAST LEADERSHIP IN. REALLY
NAVIGATING AC FIVE THROUGH SOME
OF THE VERY CHALLENGING WATERS
THAT YOU FOUNDED. EVERY VISIT
IN PROPOSITION TWO OH NINE HAS
BEEN A LONG TIME IN COMING. I'M
GLAD THIS DAY WILL NOT BE
DELAYED ANY LONGER. IN THAT
SPIRIT IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT
THIS MEASURE BEFORE THE SENATE.
ED YOU CAN GET THERE AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE I WILL NOT BE ASKING
TO BE ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR
DESPITE THE FACT THAT I. WE
WISH I COULD ADD MY NAME. TO
THIS MEASURE. SO TO SAY THAT I
HOPE YOU WELCOME IS A SPIRITUAL
CO AUTHOR. ON THIS VERY
IMPORTANT MEASURE. A LARGE PART
OF THE REASON I WISH TO BE
ADDED AS A CO AUTHORS BECAUSE I
BELIEVE THAT A C. FIVE. HELPS
US RISE TO THE- TO THE MATCH
OUR COURAGE MOMENT IN HISTORY.
I REMEMBER WATCHING NINETEEN
SIXTY FIVE. AND I REMEMBER I
JOIN THE CALIFORNIA ARMY
NATIONAL GUARD A YEAR LATER.
AND MOST OF THE TRADING WAS
REVOLVED AROUND DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE. IN STREET VIOLENCE
THAT WE HAD TO LOOK AT AND
PREPARE FOR KNOWING THAT IT MAY
COME. I REMEMBER HOW CHIEF
PARKER THE MAN WHO COINED THE
TERM THIN BLUE LINE. ACTIVELY
MAKE CHOICES THAT INFLAME THE
SITUATION. NOW REMEMBER HOW AND
IN NINETEEN SIXTY SIX THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA ELECTED
RONALD REAGAN. WHO DID NOT MAKE
FISH OF JUSTICE AND
RECONCILIATION THE CORNERSTONE
OF CALIFORNIA POLICY. I ALSO
REMEMBER THE NINETEEN NINETY
TWO RIGHT. REMEMBER MY RATE
SHOULD HOW RODNEY KING. WAS
VICIOUSLY BEATEN. BY OUT OF
CONTROL POLICE OFFICERS WHO
WERE LATER FOUND NOT GUILTY. I
REMEMBER HOW DARRYL GATES
PARADED HIS RACISM AND
MISMANAGEMENT FOR ALL TO SEE.
AND I REMEMBER MY INTENT SAID
THIS WHEN THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA SUCCUMB TO. PETE
WILSON'S ACTIONS IN PROPOSITION
ONE EIGHTY SEVEN IN NINETY FOUR
IT IS MENTIONED PROPOSITION TWO
OH NINE IN. NINETEEN NINETY
SIX. TODAY CALIFORNIA IS IT A
SIMILAR CROSSROADS. JUST AS
NINETEEN SIXTY FIVE AND
NINETEEN NINETY TWO PEOPLE OF
COLOR ARE RIGHTFULLY ANGRY AT A
LONG HISTORY OF
INSTITUTIONALIZED RACISM AND
POLICIES THAT SAY YOUR LIFE
DON'T MATTER. JUST LIKE IN
NINETEEN SIXTY FIVE IN NINETEEN
NINETY TWO. THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA THE CHANCE TO REJECT
RACISM. REJECTED
INSTITUTIONALIZED OPPRESSION
AND SAY. BLACK LIVES MATTER.
BROWN LIVES MATTER THE LIVES OF
PEOPLE OF COLOR MATTER. TWENTY
TWENTY NEEDS TO BE DIFFERENT.
THANK YOU FOR REMINDING US OF
THAT SENATOR MITCHELL WE NEED
TO CHECK IMPLICIT BIAS IN
INSTITUTIONALIZED RACISM IN ALL
AREAS OF OUR LIVES. WE NEED TO
DO WHAT WE FAIL TO DO IN
NINETEEN SIXTY FIVE IN NINETEEN
NINETY TWO AND THREE HUNDRED
YEARS BEFORE THAT. I BELIEVE
THAT A CA FIVE IS A SMALL PART
CRUCIAL STEP. TOWARDS HEALING
AND ADDRESSING THE DUBIOUS
ASPECTS OF OUR STATES LEGACY. I
BELIEVE IT SENDS THE MESSAGE
THAT THE LEGISLATURE WANTS TO
MEET THIS. FREE ONE CALIFORNIA
YIELDED TO RACISM AND WHERE WE
FAIL TO DO WHAT WAS RIGHT. AND
SHOULD THE VOTERS APPROVE AC
FIVE. I BELIEVE THAT THIS
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENT. COULD
BE THE BEGINNING OF SOMETHING
VERY IMPORTANT. CONFRONTING OUR
STATE'S LEGACY OF RACISM AND
OPPRESSION AND BEGINNING THE
DIFFICULT PROCESS OF
RECONCILIATION AND CHANGE YOU
KNOW IT'S INTERESTING THAT YOU
ALL KIND OF PERSON ICE THESE
ISSUES AS THEY COME BEFORE. I
LOOK AT MYSELF AFTER THE EVENTS
THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT DIDN'T
AND WITH ITS NINETEEN SIXTY
FIVE NINETEEN NINETY TWO OR TO
SEEING WHAT WE HEAR ABOUT. IT
UNTIL THE- I FIND THAT I AM
TRULY GUILTY BECAUSE I THOUGHT
EACH ONE OF THESE EVENTS. THAT
LIFE WOULD CHANGE AFTER THAT IT
WAS AN ANOMALY IT WAS A BAD COP
HERE OR BAD OFFICER OR- THE
CIRCUMSTANCES THERE WERE
DIFFERENT BUT THAT'S NOT HOW IT
REALLY WAS. THAT WE CAN LEARN
FROM THESE ACTIONS AND WE'D SEE
CHANGE. HI VANTAGE POINT. I
DIDN'T SEE ANYTHING DIFFERENT.
FORTUNATELY I GREW UP IN SAN
FRANCISCO MY PARENTS WERE THE
BEST THINGS THEY EVER GAVE ME
WAS THAT CULTURAL DIVERSITY
THAT I EMBRACED IT ENJOYED AND
FELT THAT THAT'S HOW IT WAS
EVERYWHERE. IT WAS AND OFTEN
THOUGHT WHEN I WAS- PULLED OVER
BY A POLICE OFFICER IN DRIVING.
THE COUPLE THINGS GO THROUGH MY
MIND FIRST ONE IS. HOW MY GONNA
TALK MY WAY OUT OF THIS. SECOND
AM I GONNA GO TO TRAFFIC SCHOOL
OR AM I GOING TO PAY THE TAKE.
THE AREA I WOULD HAVE TO. IN
THE REAL WORLD A REAL PEOPLE
FULL OF COLOR. SO I COULD FOR
ME I THOUGHT THAT WAS THE ONLY
THING THAT WENT THROUGH
ANYONE'S MIND. SO I AM GUILTY.
THE. LITTLE DID I KNOW. MAYBE
LITTLE IS ALL I WANTED TO KNOW.
TO MY ASSUMPTIONS HAVE BEEN
WRONG NOW WE HAVE TO CHANGE.
AND WE MUST TREE. ENOUGH IS
ENOUGH I'M REMINDED BY JOHN F.
KENNEDY'S ONCE QUOTED WHEN SAID.
THOSE WHO MAKE PEACEFUL
REVOLUTION IMPOSSIBLE WILL MAKE
VIOLENT REVOLUTION INEVITABLE.
WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE FLOOR
BY SENATOR MITCHELL. THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATOR HILL. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS MEMBERS
PLEASE TURN ON YOUR MICROPHONES
IN ORDER TO BE HEARD CENTER
HELD BY SENATOR HILL HI CENTER
MORALE NO CENTER MORALE NO
CENTER JACKSON HI CENTER
JACKSON HI CENTER MITCHELL HI
SENATOR MITCHELL HI CENTER PAN
HI SENATOR PAN HI THE BILL HAS
FOR VOTE IT IS OUT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH REGULATIONS. THIS
HEARING IS ADJOURNED.